ASP dotnet core from Microsoft is one of
the most popular web frameworks experienced
developer Bergin Patel will teach you how to use
dotnet six, which is the latest version. Hi guys,
and welcome to dotnet mastery. My name is Bergin.
And in this course, we will walk through the basic
foundations of dotnet core application, we will
be using dotnet six in this course, along with
Visual Studio 2022 dotnet core has been a buzzword
in the industry for a while. And recently it has
been gaining more and more attention because of
the efficiency and the advantages that it brings.
So first, let's take a look at what are all the
exciting topics that we will cover in this course.
Foundation is a basic element of any
building. And that will be the first
thing that we will learn as we explored the
fundamentals of dotnet core and its evolution,
then it's critical to understand what is new in
dotnet six when it comes to an MVC application.
So I will highlight the new features in dotnet
six with respect to the MVC application,
we will be using Entity Framework
core to setup database connection
string and perform all the
database related operation.
Once we have Entity Framework core configured, we
will be performing CRUD operations on any model.
Crud stands for create, read, update and delete.
So while we perform the CRUD operations, we will
also understand how client side and server side
validations work with dotnet core. We will display
nice alerts using temp data and toaster J S. Now
while we learn all of this one critical piece is
error solving when it comes to any programming,
I will display you some of the common errors,
and how will you approach those errors and resolve
them. Lastly, we will deploy our application to
Azure. And we will see everything live including
SQL Server, which will be hosted on Azure as well.
So you can see there is quite a few things that we
will be learning in this course. Let's get started
with all of that from the next video. In this
video, let me show you the demo application that
we will be building. We will start with an empty
project. And then we will use boots watch theme
to add a nice styling. Next we will be building
a category crud project. So when you click on
category in the navigation bar, it will open up
the page and it will display all the categories.
First thing that you notice here is we have a
create Category button. When we click there,
it takes us to category create. And
here without populating anything,
if you press the Create button, we have default
client side validation. Not just that we also
have some server side validation. Like if we enter
both name and display order to be same and hit the
create button, we have a server side validation,
that display order cannot exactly match the name.
Then we have a backdoor List button here to go
back to our index page with the category list.
We can edit any of the existing category. And
as soon as you edit or create something, we have
nice toaster alerts that you can see. Lastly,
we will implement the Delete functionality.
And on that also, we will have our alerts. So
we will see server side client side validation,
we will implement toaster alerts and take a look
at temp data. Not only that, once we complete
the application, we will be deploying that to
Azure. So that will give you a complete flow
of the application as we deploy things to Azure
along with our database. So with that, let's start
on this from the next video. Let's take a look
at all the tools that we will use in this course.
We will be using dotnet sex for our
application. So make sure to install
the latest version after add sex. For
the IDE we will be using Visual Studio.
The version that I will be using is Visual Studio
2022. There are lots of advanced features in 2022
as compared to 2019. So you can always install
the free version of Visual Studio 2022.
For our database, we will be using SQL Server.
So first you will have to install SQL Server
and then you should install SSMS which has
SQL Server Management Studio. If you have
older version of SSMS that's completely okay.
As long as you're able to connect to SQL Server
on your local machine, we will be using that
connection string, and everything will work.
So once you've installed all three of these
software's, let's continue from the next video.
This video, I want to walk you through the journey
of dotnet core dotnet core is probably the biggest
change that the dotnet language has encountered.
In 2002, Microsoft introduced web forms,
which was a revolution at that time, web forms has
its drawbacks, and there was a need to overcome
all of them. Because of that, the dotnet team came
up with a new architecture, which was dotnet MVC.
Now, even though I love MVC, and I have built
many applications in MVC, it had its flaws,
like it was created on top of the components for
web forms. Because of that, it was tied to IIS,
and ultimately, Windows operating system. But with
the evolution of web development, Microsoft had to
keep up with the changing technology. Finally, in
June of 2016, Microsoft released ASP dotnet core,
and it was the first version dotnet core is built
on top of the new dotnet core framework, it is
completely rewritten, and it is a cross platform
version. Hence it is not tied with Windows.
Also dotnet core was built with cloud in
mind. So it is extremely robust with that.
Then in August of 2018, Microsoft released
dotnet core two, and the team has been
active with releasing new versions, there
was a big change from dotnet 2.1 to 2.2,
because we had to update quite a few class
libraries. And there were a few challenges. But
since then, dotnet core team has been releasing
new versions with three 3.1 and dotnet five, which
was released in November of 2020. After that, that
is start at six which will be released in November
of 2021. We will be using the Preview version, but
whatever we learned will be the same once dotnet
six is released. So this is a small overview of
all the dotnet frameworks and their evolution.
That being said, why should when you start NET
Core as compared to the classic dotnet dotnet core
comes with many advantages. First one is
ASP dotnet core is fast and open source.
If you compare that to the traditional
dotnet applications, that have been quite
a few benchmarks, and it is very fast, when you
compare that to web forms, or even dotnet MVC
dotnet core is also cross platform, the classic
dotnet was tied to IIS and Windows. But since
the dotnet core is rewritten, it has removed that
dependency with dotnet core. We also have a built
in support for dependency injection, which saves a
lot of time and it is extremely helpful. Once you
get used with using dependency injection, you
cannot imagine your application without that.
With any programming language, it is critical
that the new updates or the new version that
are released, they should be easily upgradable.
And that is one of the feature with dotnet core.
When a new version is released, updating to that
new version does not have groundbreaking changes.
Because of that you can always keep up with the
new versions. dotnet core is also cloud friendly.
When the dotnet code was being written,
cloud architecture was kept in mind.
And because of that it is completely compatible
with all of the cloud components. And lastly,
when it comes to performance dotnet code
exceeds all of the previous versions, and even
the new versions in dotnet code that have been
released. They supersede the previous version.
The code actually gets more optimized that results
into improved performance. The ASP dotnet core
compiler will eventually optimize the entire code.
Whenever the code is re composed using dotnet
core framework dotnet course actual performance is
multiple times than any of the frameworks previous
implementation. Because of that, it is clear
that Microsoft has a long term plan with dotnet
code technology. So with that brief overview,
let's continue our learning in the next video.
In this video, before we take a look at the other
files, I will introduce you to a new concept,
which is dependency injection. ASP dotnet core
implements a simple built in dependency injection.
Container Dependency injection is an integral
part of the ASP dotnet core architecture. dotnet
core injects objects of dependency classes through
constructor by using the built in IOC container.
Before I show you what advantages dependency
injection brings, let's see a scenario where
there is no dependency injection. In a typical
application, let's see we have three pages right
now. And we have some common functionality that we
want to use across all the three pages. Like let's
say we want to send emails, and we want to access
our database in all the three pages that we have.
Now, let's imagine that on these three pages,
we need to access the database first. So what we
will do is we will create the object for database
classes on all the three pages, we will have to
open that connection, we will have to do the
database operation. And then we will have to
close the connection in all the places to do the
same and create object for email implementation
that we have in all the three pages. So you can
see this is a lot of duplicate code. On top of
that, what happens in future, if you change the
implementation of how you access the database,
or email, based on the current configuration, you
might have to make that change in all of the three
pages, which is a big mess, because right now,
it's three pages down the line, it could be 30,
or 300 pages. And the issue here is that on each
page, you will deal with creating the object
managing them as well as disposing them. And
that will be a time consuming effort when we
have to do that in all the pages. So that being
said, what is a solution to avoid all of this
and get an optimal architecture. The answer
to all of that is dependency injection.
First, let me show how this scenario would look
like. Again, we will have the three pages. And we
will have email and database functionality. These
are the common things that we had before as well.
But now we will have something special, which
is dependency injection container. So as you
can see, we have got our dependency injection
container that will have an ID email and an IDB
interface and its implementation. So inside our
container, we have the implementation of the eye
email interface and the IDB interface. When any
page will need access to these functionalities, it
will just ask the dependency injection container
to create an object of this functionality
and directly give page an object to use. So inside
the page, we will actually be using an interface.
And then dependency injection does audits magic
of passing the object when the website needs it.
That way, we do not have to deal with creating the
object disposing or managing that object inside
our pages or pages will look very clean with just
the interface. All the instance and implementation
will be done by dependency injection container.
Now in future if you want to change or replace the
email class, you do not have to make any changes
in the pages, all you have to do is just change
the implementation inside the email class. And
since we are registering that in the container,
next time when we build the project, it will
take the new implementation. So you can see we
only have to change in one place. Now. That is one
of the main advantage that comes with dependency
injection. Now in order to use dependency
injection, you can use many third party tools.
But with dotnet core, we have a built in
dependency injection container, and that has its
own advantages. So I hope that you have a short
overview of how Dependency injection is helpful.
First thing that we have to do
is we need to create our project.
I will be using Visual Studio 2022. Here we have
the recent projects on the left and on the right
hand side. We will catch start there. We want to
start by creating a new project. So we will click
that and it will display all of the templates. You
can either navigate and try to find the templates
or you can just search here for model, views
and controller. As soon as you type that,
you see there are two templates that are available
right here, we will be using the ASP dotnet core
with C sharp language, we do not want the
other language. So select the C sharp language,
or ESP dotnet core web app. And we have model
views and controller. Let's hit the next button.
And we have few more options that we have to
configure. Before writing the project name, we
can give our solution a meaningful name. So let's
say we are making our project for bulky book.
And in that you can have multiple projects
like that can be data access layer, that can be
business layer that can be web layer, and so on.
So solution name, we can keep that as bulk ebook,
and then the project name. Let's call this bulky
book Web. That way you can keep the project name
and the solution name separated. Let me change the
location to where I want to save on my computer,
and we will hit Next button. Final thing that we
have to select here is the Framework version. We
will be using dotnet six, so we will select that
in the first option. Next we have authentication
time. When you clip the authentication drop
down that are individually users account,
Microsoft Identity platform and Windows.
Right now we want to keep things simple and
understand the basic folder structures of when
an empty dotnet core MVC project is created.
So we will select None inside the authentication,
we will keep the Configure for HTTPS selected, we
did not want to enable Docker right now, because
we do not want to work with the containers.
With this configuration, let's create our project.
It will take a while right it will create the
project and it will load all of the files and
folders. Great. So once the project is created,
it will load the complete view of Visual Studio.
On the left side here we have the main panel where
we will be coding everything. And on the right
side, we have Solution Explorer, good changes
if we want to commit and some properties. Now by
mistake if you close the Solution Explorer here,
do not panic, you can open it back up by going
to views here. And we have the first option,
which is Solution Explorer. With that in
place. Let's continue from the next video.
Now that our project has been created, let's
take a look at the files and folders that we have
by default. The first thing that we should
take a look at is the project file. In order
to access the project file, you will right
click on the project name or the solution
we have our project with the website
icon here. If you right click there,
we have the added project file. When you open that
up, you will see few configuration right here.
The first section here defines what is
the target framework that we are using,
we are using dotnet six, so you can see that right
here. The next important thing inside this file
is the item group item group will contain all the
new get packages that we are using in the project.
We selected the runtime compilation, and that's
why that package has been installed. In future
we will be installing more packages when we
connect to database use Entity framework code
and so on. So in that case, when we add new get
packages to our project, a new entry will be made
inside the CS proj file or the project file. Now
usually you do not work with the project file.
But it is always good to know that we have all the
packages and the references listed in the project
file. If in case you need to access that. So
that covers our first file, which is the CS proj
or the project file. Now that we have seen the
project file, the next thing that I want to show
you is we have dependencies here and we can see
the packages that we saw previously. Inside the
project file will be installed right here. We will
be adding more packages down the road. But the
next folder that we have is the properties folder.
And inside there we have launch settings dot JSON.
In here we have the different profiles using
which we can run our application. Like you
can see inside the profiles, we have a bulky book
Add profile, and we have an IIS Express profile.
If we use the IIS Express profile, we know the
port number that will be used here is explicitly
defined. If we use the bulky book web, in that
case, it will use 5005 1001. Based on HTTPS or
HTTP, the bankbook web is the default time, what
this will do is it will run a dotnet command line,
and that will trigger the application. So if you
try to run this directly with by the key book web,
you will first see a command prompt. And
then it will launch the website on port 5001.
You can see inside the logs it is displaying all
of that. So that is one way or one profile to
run our application. If you hover on this down
arrow, you will see there is another profile,
which is ies Express. And that is the
name that we have in launch settings.
If you run with IAS Express, it will use the port
number right here for the SSL. So let me run that
and show that as well. Great, you can see it
runs on the different port that is defined
right here. So the default behavior is using the
bulky book web profile. But we will be changing
that and using IIS later on. So that was a
brief overview on non setting starting JSON.
After that the next folder that you see here
is the www root folder. If you expand that,
you will see all the static files of your project.
So any static files like CSS, JavaScript, images,
or any libraries, everything will go inside the
www root folder. The www root folder will not have
any C sharp files. This folder is only meant
to serve the static files of our application.
So we will be using the static folder extensively
throughout the course, when we are adding some
GS or some images, or any other libraries. The
www root folder will be the root folder of your
application. So always remember, if you ever
have to add any static file, it will always
go inside the www root folder. Then we have
the folders for controllers, models and view,
I will get back to them in a couple of videos.
But the file after that is app settings dot JSON.
This is the file in which we will be adding
all of the connection strings and secrets
of our application. Like you might have some
API keys, you might have some SendGrid keys,
you have stripe payment keys, any of the
static secret keys that you want to save,
we will be storing them inside app settings
dot JSON. If you expand this app settings,
you will notice that we have App Settings dot
development dot JSON. So you can create new
JSON files and it will automatically bundle
them inside app settings dot JSON. Like if
you create for another environment,
App Settings dot staging dot JSON,
then you can have App Settings dot production dot
JSON, all of them will be bundled in one umbrella.
And then based on the environment variable,
you can configure it to use the different app
settings file. Because connection string for a
database in development will be different if you
compare that to staging, preview or production.
So that way, you can go into those configuration,
we will be using just app settings dot JSON
right now, because we will be working with
the local host. Also in production, there are
multiple ways of saving secrets like you can
add them to Azure Storage world and much more.
But that is beyond the scope of this course.
To get started, you need to remember,
all of your application secrets
must be inside settings dot JSON, and not
directly inside any of your CS our class
files. We will come back to this file in the later
videos and we will add our connection string.
Now the last file that we want to take a look at
s program.cs. Let's do that in the next video.
Next we have program.cs this is the file that will
be responsible for running the application. Once
we open program.cs You can see we have a variable
builder where the web application dot create
builder is passed with the built in arguments.
When you run with the dotnet command, you can
pass custom arguments If you want with that, it
will configure the application, and it will create
the Web Application Builder object. Now in the
previous video, we saw that we can use dependency
injection with dotnet core. When we want to
register anything with our dependency injection
container, we will be doing that right here. So
let's say if we want to register our database or
email or anything else, we will have to do that
between the builder. And before we call build
on that builder object. So right here, we are
just adding one service to the container, which
is builder dot services dot add controllers with
views, we are adding the service to the container,
because we are using MVC application for our
project. If you were using razor pages, then
the service will be different. Now in the future
videos, when we configure database in our project,
and we add that to dependency injection, we will
be adding a new service here in our container, our
DB context. If you are working with any version,
prior to dotnet, six, or even some of the initial
preview versions of dotnet, six, then this file
was divided into a separate startup.cs class file.
And the services that we add to Container were
inside a method configure services. And everything
from line nine onwards was inside a configure
method. So what we have on the top is we will be
adding services to our container, then we need to
configure request pipeline. And that pipeline will
be configured from the highlighted section of your
mind might be wondering what is this pipeline,
the pipeline specifies how application should
respond to a web request. When your application
receives a request from the browser, that request
goes back and forth through the pipeline. Let me
switch to the presentation here. We have different
browsers here. And then we have a pipeline.
The pipeline specifies how application should
respond to a request that is received. When
your application receives a request from the
browser, that request goes through the pipeline.
In the pipeline, you can add items that you want.
Pipeline is made up of different middlewares.
And MVC is a type of middleware itself. So if
we want an application to be built using MVC,
we have to add that middleware. Other
example could be authentication, middleware,
authorization, middleware, and so on. What exactly
happens is when your request will go through each
of the middleware, it gets modified by them, and
eventually it is passed to the next middleware.
If that is the last middleware in the pipeline,
the response is returned back to the server.
Let's take a look at the few middlewares that we
have in our application. Let me switch back to the
code here. And you can see in the pipeline, first
we are checking if it is development or not in the
environment. If it is, then we are adding the
use developer exception page that will show you
user friendly exceptions, so that you can debug
and solve them. But if it is not development,
then we are just redirecting them to an error
page. The next middleware is HTTPS redirection.
And then we have a middleware to use our static
files that are defined in www root folder.
We also have a routing middleware, and we
have authorization middleware, and we add
authentication to our project, we will have to add
a new middleware inside the program.cs as well,
then we have using a map controller route that
will map the different pattern that we have
for MVC. Based on this routing, it will
be able to redirect a request to the
corresponding controllers and action, then
you should always keep in mind that order of
pipeline is extremely important. The way
you write middlewares in the pipeline,
that is exactly how the request will be passed.
So first, routing will be done. And it checks for
authorization and so on. So in this scenario, if
you want to use authentication to your pipeline,
we have a middleware, which is app dot use
authentication. But if you do this, then it won't
work. Because authentication middleware should
always come before you authorize a user. Because
you only authorize the user that is authenticated.
That is the basic fundamentals of authentication
and authorization. So if you place the pipeline
in some different order that will break things.
Inside the endpoints. Here, you can see we have
a controller name and action name, and some
ID. This controller route will make more sense
when we understand routing. In the next video.
Let me show you more details on how routing
works. I won't be running the application to
show you that, but I want to walk you through some
theory. You can see when it comes to routing in
MVC application, we have controllers, and we
have actions. Before we explore the routing,
let me walk you through the main components
of an MVC application, which is models,
views and controller. Let me switch back to
the presentation and give you a brief overview.
Now, if you remember, we had three folders for
models, views and controllers, and that is what
MVC stands for. The first thing in MVC is model,
which represents the shape of the data. A class in
C Sharp is used to describe a model. The model
component corresponds to all the data related
logic that user works with. Let's say inside your
application, you have a table that stores all the
category or all the product details than that
product will be a model itself. model basically
represent all the data in your application, it can
be a table that you are storing inside SQL Server,
or it can be a model, which will be a combination
of multiple tables, and so on. This model can
either represent the data that is being
transferred between views and controllers,
or any business related data model that will
represent all the tables of the database. So
if you have 10 tables in your database, we will
have at least 10 models that corresponds to them.
There is also more complexity, but we will go into
those details later on. Right now you can think of
all the tables in your database will be a
class file, which will be a model than all
the properties of that class file will be the
columns of the table. That is a simple relation
that you can think of right now. Then we
have view in an MVC, which is the user
interface. You can be tired of HTML and CSS that
you write, to make things fancy and beautiful.
Whatever you see on the website with your eyes, is
basically the view that is being displayed to you.
But now you need to think of what happens if in
a website, you have a button and you click that
button. What happens is that view will interact
with your model to display some of that data. But
view does not interact directly with the models.
For that we have something known as controller
controller acts as an interface between model
and view to process all the business logic and
incoming request. So controller acts as an
interface between model and view to process
all the business logic and it manipulates that
data using model and interacts with the view
to render the final output. This is just a brief
overview of how model views and controller works.
So let's say if a user clicks on a button
controller is the first thing that will receive
that request and controller will have lots of
action methods based on those action methods
controller will redirect the request to one of the
action method and controller will use the model it
will fetch all the data that it needs to display
inside the view. Once the view is rendered,
it will pass all of that to the controller and
controller will then pass a response which will be
sent back and the user will finally be able to see
the page. So you can see controller can be treated
as heart of your application. That is where
we will have all the logic of your application
and it is the one which will be interacting
with models and views. So with that in place,
now you see that the request first comes to the
controller and it's action methods. So with that
general idea if we go back you can see inside the
map controller route, we have a pattern where we
define a controller and an action method. So
here we are saying that the default if nothing
is provided It should go to the home controller,
and it should call the index action method.
But that is a 10,000 Fate overview. Let's take a
look at routing a little more with some theory.
Before we see routing in action, let's see
routing with some examples. You can see here
we have a general pattern of routing. The first
thing highlighted in blue here is the domain of
the URL. When we run on the local computer,
you will have a local host and a port number.
Whatever it is, after that port number will be
the route that we want to use when we are calling
a page to be loaded. In the first example,
you see we have something called as category,
then we have an index and some number. When we
are working with MVC, after our port number,
or domain, whatever is the first thing that
we have will be the name of the controller,
then the next forward slash after that will be
the action of the controller. And after that,
if you have something that will be the ID.
This is the pattern of routing with MVC.
If we go back to the application, you can see
the same format right here. First we have the
controller name, then forward slash, we have an
action name, then forward slash, we have the ID
that corresponds with the request that we have
here. Keep in mind that ID is an optional field,
controller and action are not optional. But if
they are not defined, we have set a default route,
that if there is no controller and action, you
can use home controller and index action as the
default route. Because of that, we have our home
controller. And we also have the index action,
which I will show you. Before we dive into those
details. Based on the understanding that we have
here, I have given some sample URL, I want you
to try to find out what will be the controller,
action and Id based on this URL, I can remember
if controller is not defined default, one that
we have in our application is let's go back the
home controller. And if the action is not defined,
that will be index action. So based
on that the first URL that we have,
the controller name is category, the action is
index. And we do not have any ID. For the next
one, we have controller name as category, we do
not have any action. So index will be the default
action. And finally, ID is no. Next what we have.
For the third one, we have controller as category
action as added and ID as three. The last one,
we have controller product action details,
and we have ID as three. So with that if you get
a URL, now you can identify what is the controller
name, what is the action name, and if there is
an ID or not. So with that brief understanding of
routing, let's actually run our application,
see routing in action in the next video.
Now we want to understand routing in MVC. This
is one of the tricky topics that I had when I
first started learning MVC. So I want to make
sure that you get familiar with the routing.
Before we see the complete routing in
action. Let me walk you through the
three folders that we have. We have a folder
for controller, we have a folder for models,
and we have a folder for views. By default, we
have a home controller that has been created.
models will be all the data related
models that people want in the project.
So let's say if you are dealing with products
that you want to display on the page,
you will have a product model and we will be using
that model in controller and views. Right now you
can just think of models as tables that you want
in your database. If you want a product table,
you will have a product model. That is not always
the case, but we will explore models later on.
The main thing that we want to work on
is understanding controllers and views.
Controller is the heart of the application. At
the same time views is what will be displayed on
the screen when user is looking at the page. Now
the way navigation works is when we have a home
controller, all of the views or UI pages that are
displayed with the home controller will be placed
inside the same folder name as the controller
name So you can see they have also created a home
folder by default, that is also a convention with
the naming of controllers, it should always end
with the keyword of controller. That is how the
application will know that this is a controller.
If we expand our home controller, you will see
some code right here, we have a class with the
name of home controller, and it implements
the default or the base class of controller.
And right here we are registering the logger using
dependency injection. Do not go into that detail
right now, I will explain dependency injection in
much detail. But for now, to understand routing,
you can see we have two action methods. Inside
controllers, you can have multiple action method.
If we go back to the URL here, you can notice
that we have the controller name and action name.
If the URL was forward slash home, forward slash
privacy, then it will go to Home controller look
for a privacy action method. And it will load the
content that we have here. The return type for an
action method is I action result, because I action
result is an abstraction for multiple return type,
it can return a view, it can redirect to some
action method, or it can redirect a page. And much
more than I said that if the URL is home forward
slash index, it will return the view that we
have defined here. Now you might be thinking that
where is this view we are talking about that view
will be inside the views folder. The way it finds
our maps, the view for this index action method
is inside the views folder, it will look for the
name of the controller, which is home controller.
So we have that folder. Inside there, we will have
a view with the name of this action method. And
it is index action method. So that will be mapped
to this particular view. If we open that view,
we have some HTML and Bootstrap classes. So
here, nothing fancy is going on, we are just
displaying some text. So let's run our application
and see routing in action. Right now it will run
in the command prompt window. And once that
is done, it will run the website on port 5001.
In the URL right now, nothing is present. What
should happen if there are no controllers and
actions in the URL, we define that inside the
program.cs. We said if nothing is present,
default that to home controller and index
action method. So what we see on the screen
is from the home controller index action method
to confirm that if you go to the home controller,
you can add a debugging point by clicking anywhere
on the window. What that will do is when it hits
this controller, this will be yellow. So if we go
back, and if we refresh the page, you can see it
hits our breakpoint here. So that means if nothing
is present in the URL, it is calling the home
controller index action method. Let me also add a
debugging point inside the privacy action method.
So we will hit continue here and the request goes
back. So we will hit continue. And then here we
have returned view that will find out the view
that is associated, and it will display that on
the page. If you right click on the view here, you
have linked to go to the view, if you click that,
it will automatically redirect you to the index
view because it knows it has to find the home
folder inside there, there will be an index view.
This is how controllers and views are associated.
So if we go back to the application, while this is
running, we have the Privacy tab here. And you can
see on the bottom right the URL that it will go to
is home forward slash privacy. So what will be the
controller name, controller name will be home and
action name will be privacy. So it will go to the
home controller. It will go to the privacy action
method and it will return the view. The view is
inside home we have privacy and it should display
this particular paragraph. Let's go back and hit
that. It hits our debugging point. That is great.
Let's continue and it displays the privacy policy.
So that is perfect. With this you can see
how routing is working in action. With MVC
based on the URL, you have to define
the controller name and action name,
it goes to the controller points out that action
method. And it returns a view based on the view
that you have defined inside the views folder.
Now, if this is too much right now, do not worry,
just understand the basics that I have taught you
in this video. But as we proceed with the course,
routing will make much more sense. And
if this is too much for you do not worry,
you are not alone. When I was learning MVC, about
10 years ago, at that time, I had a very hard time
trying to understand this since I
was coming from the webform world,
where we just have code behind files. So as we
program this more, it will get much more familiar.
And you will love the way it works. So
let's continue from the next week here.
Now that we have seen the basic controllers and
views and how the interaction works with routing,
I want to walk you through the basic views that
are available with our project. We saw the home
folder inside views that corresponds
to the views of the home controller.
But on top of that, we have something called a
shared shared folder is used for partial views.
And partial views are similar to user components
if you are coming from classic C sharp.
So it's basically a view that you can call within
a view in multiple places in your application.
Along with that, we have a special partial
view, which is underscored layout. And this
underscored layout is the default master page
of your application. So if you open that up,
you can see we have some styling on the top here,
we have a header right here. And we have a div
where we render the body, since this is the
master page, so whatever we display inside the
other views, it will use this underscored layout
as the default master page. So inside index,
when we are displaying this content, it was
displaying that with the navigation on the top, we
also have a footer here. And we have some common
JavaScript that we want across the application.
We have the main HTML and body tag. And we have
head right here, where we are adding the styling.
We will be updating this in future videos.
Whenever we want to add some CSS and JS
globally. This is the place where we will be
adding that next we have elation scripts partial,
and this is a partial view where we are just
adding scripts for some validations. Wherever
in some views, let's say in index view, we want to
use validations, then we will include this partial
view on that page. So that way, we do not have
to write those script tags, we will just include
this partial view, and that will be included.
We also have an error partial view that will be
used to display the errors. If you encounter in
the application. We will be adding more partial
views as we proceed with the course. So do not
worry. But remember shared folder will contain
all the partial views. And underscore layout
is the master page of your application.
While the application is running, if I switch
back quickly, you can see on the privacy page,
we have the header here, we have the footer here,
and we have the body. So where we have this render
party at that place, whatever we had inside the
privacy, these two lines are being displayed. So
I hope that makes sense. Then we have something
called as underscore view import and underscore
view start. Let me open the view import first.
And we have the global namespace right here.
So inside your application, let's say you
want to access some namespace in all of the
pages. If you add that USING statement here,
it will be accessible across all the pages,
controllers and classes in your project. That way
you do not have to type this namespace every time.
We will see that in action as
we proceed with the course.
But one important thing that you see here is tag
helpers. helpers are bindings that are provided
by the dotnet core team that looks like HTML
tags. But they are special tags that are adopted
by the Microsoft team from other languages. After
looking at the success like Angular and react,
I will show you one example quickly here
in the underscored layout. If we go back to
our application we'll click on privacy to see it
builds the URL home and privacy. Here we know that
home is controller and action name is privacy.
So how do you think this link is provided on this
navigation, it is provided using a special Tag
Helper. Let me expand the header here. And you
can see we have an anchor tag. And then we have
tag helpers. For ASP controller and ASP action.
Tag helpers will start with a prefix of ASP
hyphen, and then the name. So here we have
attack helper, which says ASP controller, and
then we define the controller name for routing.
And in that controller, what action name should
be calmed. So that is ASP action. Do not worry
about the ASP areas for now. We will be
using lots of tag helpers that are provided
by the dotnet team in future by tag helpers
have been included in the project. And we
define them globally. Inside the view imports
file. The last file inside the views folder
is the view start. This file will define what
is the default master page for your application.
In set privacy, you see we have not defined what
will be the master page. But it is by default,
using underscored layout, because that is what
has been defined inside the view start file.
If you want to explicitly define
a master page for privacy,
which is different, you can do that directly
by defining that on the top. And that will take
preference over what is defined in view start
but you start will have the default master page
for the application. Now I know the section
was a little bit lengthy, but this overview
was critical when it comes to understanding
the default views that have been provided.
In this video, let's take a look at tag helpers.
Tag helpers are brand new to ESP dotnet core.
Microsoft looked at the success around libraries
like Angular, React, and decided that implementing
an Angular directive like experience in the new
ASP dotnet was so important to the adoption of
dotnet core that they decided to create tag
helpers from crowns up. Even though there are
similarities between Angular directives and tag
helpers, there is a major difference. Tag helpers
are for server side rendering, while the Angular
JS directives are all about client side rendering.
If you have worked with older versions of dotnet
core, we had something called as HTML helpers.
They are still around a tag helpers are being
modern with the tag like approach. So it's much
user friendly. Tag helpers are very focused around
the HTML element and are much more natural to us
as compared to HTML helpers. We will be working
with Tag helpers many times in the application.
But to just give you a brief overview, you can see
in the first tab here we have HTML helpers, and
tag helpers simplifies all of them, because we can
use the existing label tag. And we will just add
a Tag Helper ESP four, and we will find that to a
model. We have same Tag Helper right here as well.
Then in the last example, here I am displaying tag
helpers where previously we were using HTML dot
begin form. And now within the same form tag, we
have the tag helpers of where it should be posted.
So you can see things are getting much more
simpler when we are using Tag helpers. That
being said, if you're coming to dotnet, brand
new, and you have never worked with HTML helpers,
this is even better. You do not
have to worry about the old syntax
and what is different. We will be working
with Tag helpers in the upcoming videos.
But I just wanted to give you a brief snippet
of what tag helpers are and how they look like.
When we are using the same tags, we just use
the ASP hyphen and then the Tag Helper name.
That being said, we will explore all of this
in much more details in the upcoming videos.
When you will be working with
a dotnet core application,
you will see the return type of action
result. And it does not matter if you're
using an MVC application or a razor page
application. In both the cases you can see
we have eye action result in MVC We are
returning back view in this example. And in
razor PAGE PAGE handler, we are returning back to
the page. But the return type is I action result.
I action result is a generic type that implements
all of the other return types. Now, if you want to
be explicit about the return type in both of these
cases, then that would look something like this.
If the return type is view, you can write View
Result. But in razor pages, when we return back
to page, you can write page result. So now what
is the advantage of action result? So first,
let's understand some theory. So action result is
a pattern class for many of the derived classes
that have associated helpers. The eye action
result return type is appropriate when multiple
action results return type are possible in
an action. Let's take a look at some of the
helpers and action wizard. So first, let's
take a look at what is there in razor pages.
A razor page can return content file not found
page a partial result, and redirect to different
pages. For all of them, we have returned types
like content result, file content result,
not found result, page result, partial result, and
so on. If you are working with an MVC application,
we can return back views, partial views, we can
redirect to action, return JSON and so on. So
if you are returning any one of these, then you
can use the individual return types for result
based on the helper method. But what if
you were returning something like this?
Right here in MVC, you can see we are returning if
true, let's imagine that was some condition here.
Based on that if that condition is
true, you want to redirect to action,
else you want to return to view this time you
cannot have two different return types. If you
use View Result here, return view is working,
but redirect to action will throw an error.
Similarly, if you use redirect to action result,
then redirect to action works. But return view
will give you better if you are working on
razor pages and you have the same situation.
If you use page result, and return page will
work. But redirect to page will fail. And if
you use redirect to page result, then return page
will fail. So what is the solution to all of this,
the solution is to use I action result in both
places. Because this is a parent class. So it
does not care which of its implementation is being
returned, it will be able to handle all of them.
So that is a brief overview on how action
wizard will help us with the return type
from action method in MVC application or
page handlers in a razor page application.
Now that the project has been created, there
are few files and folder structures right
here. We will go into all of this files and folder
structure in the upcoming videos. But right now,
inside the views folder, we have home. And inside
there, we have index.cs. HTML. This is the default
home page of our application. So if I open this
up, you will see there is some welcome text here
and a paragraph, which is inside a div tag. Let's
run our application and see what is the output.
It loads up the default page of the website
where we have the project name here,
a homepage and a privacy page. You can
see on the homepage, we have some text
right here. And that HTML is exactly same as what
we see inside the index.cs. HTML. I do not want to
go into much technical details. But let's say
you are making some changes inside your view.
If you save that, you go back to the application.
And if you refresh here, you're directly see the
changes right here. If you notice in Visual Studio
2022 There is this icon, which is for hot reload.
This is a great capability that has been added
with dotnet sinks. If this does not refresh
and reload for you. You can go here and make
sure the hot reload on File Save is enabled.
What that will do is whenever you make some
change here and you save if you go back refresh,
you can see the change is
being reflected in the UI.
This is very helpful when you are designing
something with MVC or razor application.
But if you notice the first time, you had
to manually come to the page and refresh,
and after that the hot reload automatically works.
So I wanted to walk you through that advantage.
Now, if you were working with an application,
which is not in dotnet, six, then you will have
to right click on the project, and you will have
to add a new get package by clicking the Manage
nougat package. You will search for a package
runtime compilation. And you can see we have
Microsoft that ASP NET Core dot MVC dot razor
dot one time this package was needed before,
so you can hit the Install button to add that to
our project. Even though that is not needed here,
I still want to add that then you will
have to go to program.cs. And right here,
we only have ADD controllers with view. When you
add razor pages, you will add builder dot services
dot add razor pages. And on there you will have
to enable the Add razor runtime compilation.
But because of hot reload and the magic
that we have, this is no longer required.
So in the future videos, when we will be adding
the razor pages, I also add the razor runtime
compilation, because when the video was originally
recorded in dotnet, six, hot reload was still in
testing. So that's why I have added the razor
one time compilation down the road. But you can
skip that and you will just add the builder dot
services dot add razor pages. So that's a brief
overview that I wanted to give you with the heart
reload in dotnet six. That being said in the next
video, let's first examine all the files and
folder structures that have been created here.
When we work with any project, the main piece
or the heart of the application is the data.
And we need a database to store our data. So we
will be using SQL Server to create a database
and store all the data for our website. With
dotnet core, you might have heard about term
condors Entity Framework core as well. If not,
do not worry. But Entity Framework core is what
we'll be using to create database and we will be
using the same to perform all the data operations.
So with dotnet core, you do not need stored
procedures or writing SQL statements in the
code. Entity Framework is a spot editor that will
help us with all the data related operations.
That makes sense, it does not mean that you cannot
use stored procedures, you can still use stored
procedures if you want. But typically with MVC
application Entity Framework core is used to
manipulate the data layer. We will go into those
details in the upcoming videos. But right now,
we first need to create our model model will
basically resemble a table in database. It is
not always the case. But whatever tables you have
in your database, you will need a corresponding
model for the code first migration. So inside the
Models folder, we only have added view model. Let
me create one more model here, we will right
click there. And we will add a class file.
We want to create a table for category. So we will
call our model as category. And let's add that
it creates a public class file and it places it
inside the namespace of bulky book web doc models.
That is just the location so it knows that it
is inside bulky book web Models folder. That
is the category class right here. Now inside
this category class, we need to create all the
properties that we found. For our table. We
want to create ID name and a display order.
So to start we can write prop and it is a code
snippet. So once your type prop and hit tab two
times it will automatically create a property
the ID column we will keep that as integer
and I will call that as ID. Next property that we
want to create will be the name of the category
that will be a string. So we will create that
we press prop again we want to display order.
Now display order will be an integer so Let me
add that. On top of that, let's say for logging
purpose, we want to create a date time property,
which will have the date on when this category was
created. So we will call this created date time.
Now the created date time, let's say we want to
set a default value to that. So in order to do
that we can use equal to sign. And we can just
assign the date time dot now like this. That way,
the default value will automatically be assigned
to the created date time when we create an object
of this class. So perfect, we have created our
model. And then we want to push this model to our
database to create a table with this four columns.
But when we create a database table, we might want
to add some more configuration. Like we might want
to see that id is a primary key. And since it's an
integer, we want to make that an identity column.
So we do not have to populate that when we create
a row inside the new table that we will create.
We could also add a validation that name
is a required property. And it should not
be now if we had to write a SQL statement,
we could have done all of that by using not
an identity in our SQL script. But how
will we do that using Entity Framework
for that dotnet team has come up with alternatives
called as data annotation. So on the property
where you want to configure some more details,
we have special attributes that you can use.
Let me walk you through them in the next video.
Now we want to configure some of the requirements
that we have in a SQL script. Like we want to make
this ID column, an identity column, which will
be the primary key of this table. In order to do
that, we have a data annotation, or an attribute
known as key. If you enter that, you notice
the red squiggly lines. If you hover on that,
it will display an error, that key attribute
could not be found. That is because we have
to add a USING statement. So you need to make sure
your keyboard is on the key. And then if you press
control.it will display that you can add USING
statement to resolve this. So we will press enter,
that will add the USING statement which
has the data annotation that we want.
Once this key annotation has been applied,
it will tell Entity Framework core that hey,
when you create a script to create this table,
you need to make sure that it is a primary key.
And it should also be an identity column. It
does all the configuration and talking by itself.
We just need to write one attribute and everything
will be done for us. Pretty simple, right.
The next thing that we wanted to do is we want
to make sure that name is a required property.
So here we have another attribute, which
is required. Once you assign that when
it creates the script, it will make sure
that name is not an allowable property.
Now we have talked about these two, but there are
more annotations that you can do for validation.
With this in place, the initial equation of
our model looks good. How do we create that
in our database. Now, let's take
a look at that in the next video.
have added the data and rotations 10 We have
created our model, we need to create a table and
a database inside SQL Server. So let me open up
SQL Server Management Studio. Make sure you have
that installed on your machine because that is
what we will be using to play with the database.
Once the SQL Server Management Studio opens up,
we will be using our local database. Now for some
of the users it could be local TP backward slash
MSSQL local DB. For others, it could be just a dot
I have both of the server name configured. So
I will use any one of them and I will hit the
connect button. As long as it is able to connect
that server name is what you will be using inside
your connection string. If you use something else,
then it won't work. So I will be using dot. But on
your end you need to check if dot works. You
can use that or the local DB MS SQL local DB
should also work. Let's hit cancel here. And if
we expand the databases, you can see we have few
database here but I want to create a new database
for Project. So for that, we have to create a
connection string inside our project. In order
to store all of the secrets of your application,
you will be doing that inside the app settings dot
JSON file. You can hard code the connection string
inside the class file. That is a bad approach.
App Settings dot json file is the file where
you should have all the secrets. That way, if you
have to update anything in the future, you know,
it will be available inside the app settings dot
JSON file. And then you can create different app
settings for different environment. Like if you
have development, staging, preview production,
you can create all of those app settings. And
you can configure to use that app settings
when you deploy the application. That way based on
your environment name, you can use different app
settings, or different database and so on, we will
be working directly in App Settings dot JSON. And
that should work with the local development. So
this is a simple JSON file. Now we'll be add a new
connection string in here. As you can see, it is
just a dictionary with string key and value pairs.
What you have inside logging is known as
a block, where inside the locking block,
we have another block of log level. And that
has three key value pairs. So we can either
create a block, or we can directly configure the
connection string. Now the dotnet team thought
that connection string is very common, and almost
all of the projects will have a connection string.
That is why they have created a default block for
connection string that we can use. If we want,
you can use something else. But you can also use
the default block name that they have given. If
you see it is automatically suggesting me that
block name, which has connection strings, we can
use something else. But I want you guys to use the
exact same name for now. And I will also tell you
the reason behind that in the upcoming videos. So
inside this block, we will have a key value name.
So that key name, you can use whatever you want, I
will just use default connection, you can use any
name that you want for the key right here. And
we need to paste our enter a connection string
within the double quotes on the right side. So
the first parameter here will be the server name,
I am using.so That is what I will write
if you are using a different server name,
like if we go back to SQL Server. And if you
were using the MS SQL local DB to connect,
I want you guys to copy this, go back to the
application and paste that here. I am using
the local server with a card. So that is what I
will use. And then we need the next parameter.
If you have to separate anything in a connection
string, we will use a semi colon. The next
property that we have is the database name. Let's
call this bulky. Then after that, we want to set
the trusted connection flag to be true. Make sure
there is no spelling mistake here. And that is all
that we want to configure in the connection
string. You can make it more complicated,
but we will keep things pretty simple. We have a
database name that we want to create inside this
particular server that we are able to connect in
SQL Server and the cluster connection is true.
That way when we connect here, we
can just use Windows authentication.
If you have a user ID and password, then you can
use the different settings in connection string,
I will be using the default crusted connection.
So with this we are using a special block that is
available with the name of connection string.
In there we have a key of default connection
and value has the connection string. Now how can
we use this connection string to actually create
the database and create our category table inside
the database. Let's do that in the next video
we need to tell our application that we
will be using SQL server and you have to
use this connection string to establish the
connection with SQL Server. For that we will
be using Entity Framework core and we will
have to create an object of the DB context.
Using that DB context we will be able to make
connection to the database. So how do we do that?
It is best to create a new folder for all
the data related changes. So here let me
create a new folder with the name of data
In SEC there, we will create our DB context,
we will create a class here. And I will call that
application DB context. You can use any name that
you want here, but I'm using DB context so that
it's easy to identify. Let's add that class file.
Now we need to inherit this class file from the
DB context that is inside Entity Framework core.
In our project, we have not added Entity Framework
core right now. So there are two ways to add that
we know that this will inherit from the
DB context. So we can type that and you
will see the red squiggly lines on there, if
you press Control dot inside the suggestions,
it will display that you can install a
package Microsoft dot Entity Framework core
that will automatically find an install the latest
version. If you want to do that yourself, you can
right click on the project. And you can select
Manage NuGet packages, or you can go to tools,
we have new get package manager, and we can
open up manage nougat packages for solution.
Here, you will have to go to the Browse tab to
see all the new get packages that are available.
Now right now I'm using dotnet
six with the preview version.
So I have checked the include pre release
right here. The package that we are looking
for is Entity Framework core. Let's press Enter.
And the first package is Microsoft dot Entity
Framework core. We are using the previous seven.
So let me select that. And we will install that.
Once that is installed, if we go
back to our application DB context,
and now if we press Control dot here, it will tell
us that we just have to add the USING statement,
since we have already installed the package.
So we've add the USING statement for our DB
context. Once we do that, then there is one line
of configuration that we have to do inside the
constructor of this class file. You can think
of that as the general syntax that is needed
to establish the connection with Entity Framework.
So first, we need to create a constructor,
you can type C, D or R and press tab twice. You
can see it is a code snippet for constructor.
So once you press tab twice, it should
automatically create the constructor, we just
have to write some parameters here. Because when
we get the DB context, we need to pass that on
to the base class, which is dB context. So here,
we will have to configure the DB context options
on the class that we are on right now, which is
application DB context, we can paste that here.
And I will call this options. So here we
are saying that in the constructor here,
we will receive some options. And those
options, we just have to pass to the base class,
which is dB context. This is a general setup that
you have to do that will configure our DB context.
Now once you configure our DB context, we still
have one main feature, we still have to create
our category table inside the database.
So whatever models that you have to create
inside the database, you will have to create
a DB set inside the application DB context,
the file that we are currently working on. Now
how do you create a DB set that is pretty simple,
we will say public DB set here, and we need
to write the model name. That model name is
category. And once you write that, you can see the
red squiggly lines. That is because it cannot find
anything with the name of category in the same
file, we need to add the USING statement to tell
it that category is inside the Models folder. So
if you press ctrl.we have that USING statement.
Let's add that and the next parameter here is the
table name. So if you call this categories then
inside database the table that will be created
will be called as categories and not category.
So that looks good. And we will add the getter
and setter. That's all that we had to do
to create the category table. What this will do
is it will create a category table with the name
of categories and it will have four columns
that we have wrote inside the category model
when it creates stack table it will make sure that
ID is an identity column and name is a required
field as well. So, you can see it is doing all the
configuration by writing just few lines of code.
Now, when you are working with Entity Framework
core, there are two models, one is code first
and one is database first what we are doing is
code first, because here we are writing the code
of our model and based on that model, we will
be creating the database. So, that is the code
first approach database first approach will be
something right database is already created. And
based off that database, you will be scaffolding
models. I personally am a big fan of code first.
And that is what I have been using in all of my
production application. Because I do not come
from a DBA management point of view, I am more of
a full stack developer who works with the code.
So if Entity framework code will manage database
for us, I will be very happy with that approach.
So with that we have added our
DB set for the category table.
But we are missing one small configuration or
application still does not know that it has
to use the connection string that we wrote
in app settings. And it still does not know
that it has to use Application DB context to
create a DB context and that it has to work
with SQL Server. So let's see how we can
pull everything together. In the next video,
we just need to tell our application that it
has to use the DB context which has inside
application DB context. And then it has to use a
SQL Server using the connection string that were
defined inside the app settings dot JSON. We will
tell our application to do that inside program.cs
where we configure the services that our
application will use. So here we have the comments
to add the services to the container make sure
you always do that before you build the builder.
So right here, we want to add a new service. So on
builder dot services, the surface that we want to
add is dB context. So you can see we have dot
add DB context and that expects a class file
the class file that we are using for DB context
is the application DB context. If you press
control.we will just have to add the
USING statement to the Data folder.
Now, when we configure this DB context, if
we go back to the application DB context,
right here, we are passing the options and we
are sending those options to the base class. So
inside options, we have to configure use of SQL
Server and connection string. So here we will see
options goes to this is just the syntax, we will
say options dot that is a method with the name of
use SQL Server, but it will not be available like
that, even if you press control.it will not give
you the package name that you have to add. So for
that, we will have to go back to the Manage nougat
packages. And we will have to install a package
which is SQL Server with Entity Framework core,
which is Microsoft dot Entity Framework core
dot SQL Server. Make sure you are using the
consistent version. If one version of the package
you are using is preview seven and other one is
preview five, or even dotnet five, and things
won't work and you will run into error message.
So always make sure that you
are using the same version.
Let me install the SQL Server and we will close
the nougat packages. Now if you press ctrl dot,
you will see the USING statement using Microsoft
dot Entity Framework core. We will add that and
on the SQL Server we have to write the connection
string. So where exactly is our connection string.
That is inside app settings, we used a special
block with the name of connection strings.
Since we put our connection string inside this
special block theme that I was talking about,
we can directly use the key value
here to extract the connection string.
Let me copy this name. We will go
back to our program.cs and right
here on builder dot configuration, we have an
existing method that is provided which is get
connection string. Inside this method we have to
pass the string name which is default connection
Once you use that, it will automatically find the
connection string and configure our SQL Server.
Now this cat connection string is a
special method. And this method will
only look for this default connection inside
a block with the name of connection strings.
If you named this connection strings one, then it
will not be able to find this connection string,
because this method will only look inside
the block, which is connection strings.
So that is why I said to name it exactly the
same, if you wanted to name it something else,
we have different ways of getting that. But I
do not want to go into those details right now.
So with this, our DB context will be
configured with the connection string.
So all the configuration is done that was needed
for the DB context. Now we are on the final step,
where we have to create database, and then the
table inside SQL Server. Let's take a look at that
in the next video. Now that the
program.cs has been configured,
the next step that we have is to actually
create the database and the table.
When you are using Entity framework code.
First, there are migrations that you have
to run using Entity Framework to push the changes
to database. It is not as complex as it sounds,
we have done all the setup that is needed. In
order to run the migration, you will go to Tools
NuGet package manager, and this time, you will
select the package manager console. The first
thing that you have to do is you have to add
a migration. Migration is basically keeping a
track of all the DB changes that are needed. And
once that migration is created, you push that
migration to the database to actually create
the database or make changes to your table.
Let's see what that is. The command to add a
migration is add hyphen, migration. And then we
have to give our migration a meaningful name. Do
not use any spaces when you are writing the name.
The name that I want to give to our migration is
Add category to database. Let's hit the Add button
and we see an error message. The error is because
when you run add migration, you have to add a new
get package. You see the term add migration is
not recognized. I want you guys to copy this error
and try to find out what is the package that is
missing from Google. I can give you the answer
directly. But I want you guys to Google what
package is required based on this error message.
If you just copy that error and paste it here, you
will see the very first and if you scroll down,
you will see the package name. It is so simple.
Just install Microsoft dot Entity Framework core
dot tools. That is the package that is required
to enable migrations in your project. Whenever
you face any error, it is best to just Google
that error. That way you can find the solution
much easily and much quicker. So let's go to
our project manage nougat packages, we will
paste the package name, and we will install
the same version that we have in our project.
Perfect that is done, we can close this, I can
open up the package manager console again. And
I will run the same command one more time.
This time it should complete successfully.
And if you notice on the right hand side here, a
new folder with the name of migrations is created.
And there are two files that got added. Our
migration file is the first one and that is opened
up on the screen as well. Inside migrations, we
have two methods, one is up and one is down. The
up method is what needs to happen inside the
migration and down is if something goes down,
we need to rollback the changes. So do
not worry about the download right now.
Let's see what's happening inside the app
method. On the migration builder, we have
a method with the name of CREATE TABLE and it is
creating that table with the name of categories.
That is the exact name that we defined right
here. So it will create a table with the name
of category and then that will have columns. The
first column will be the ID column which will be
of the type integer and nullable is false. Since
we said it is a key column, it is automatically
making that an identity column and increment
that one every time. Pretty smart, right?
The next thing is the name column. And you
can see the nullable is false here. If you
did not add the required property, that nullable
would be true, you will say that display order
is also a nullable false, but we did not add that
inside category. And the reason behind that is
it is an integer property and not a string.
That is why nullable is false, because it's
an integer. Last, we have the created date time
of the type date time too. And that looks good.
If you see on the constraints, it is also adding
a primary key on the ID column with a name. So
migrations is exactly what we wanted. But can
we take a look at the sequel that gets executed?
Now, what Entity framework code does is
based on this migrations, it will create
an optimized version of the SQL query. And it
will automatically run that on the database,
you do not have to do anything with that what
you work with is just the models, you create a
migration and you push that to the database. So
once you verify that migration is looking good,
you can just run the command update database.
And that will push the migrations to database.
We have an error here, let me go to app settings.
And of course, we do, this will not be colon,
this will be equal to right here, and they
are separated by a semicolon. That was my bad,
we will go back to the package manager. And you
can also see the error said server and colon was
not supported, because it should be equal
to let's update the database one more time.
Perfect the migrations were completed. But what
actually happened is first it will connect to the
server, it will check is there a database with the
name of palki there won't be anything right now.
So it will create that database first. And then
the migrations here, it will convert them to SQL
and execute them on our database. So if we go
back, now, if we refresh the database, you will
see the new database with the name of bulky and
if you open the tables, that will be two tables.
Let's examine the columns
inside the Categories table.
It should have four columns. And that looks
great. Now what is inside the EF migrations,
if you do the Select Top 1000 entity framework
code keeps a track of which migrations have been
applied. So next time when you run the update
database, it will not apply the same migration,
it will only apply the migrations that
have not been applied on this database.
Entity framework code is pretty smart with all
the configuration and cracking that it needs to
do. So with that, using Entity Framework core, we
have created our database. And we have added our
table based on the model inside our main project.
So with that, let me continue in the next we do.
Now before we work on anything
else, that we run the project.
Right now it is running on port 5001. Let me
change that so that the command prompt is not
opened every time, we can just run that using
IIS profile by clicking here. That way it won't
run on the port 5001 It will get the new port that
is defined in the project config, I'm getting an
error that I'll have to open Visual Studio under
an admin account. So let me do that real quick.
With it open the project again. We have the IIS
Express here. Let's try to run it this time.
And perfect. So we have home and privacy but both
of these pages are inside the home controller.
Now in category we will be creating editing
and deleting category. So for that rather
than working on the home controller, let's
create a new controller for our category.
So inside the controllers folder, we will
right click Add a controller and we have
few options here. We will go with the empty
controller to keep things very simple and start
from scratch. I will call that as category
controller. Now when you name a controller,
make sure that you append controller at the end.
That is a required field. Whatever name you want,
must come before the controller. So once you
have that name, we will click the Add button.
For effect we get an empty control With an
index action method, our home controller
also had the index action method. And our category
controller also has the index action method. But
the index action method in home controller
has a view that is inside the home folder.
Our category action method does not have a view
right now, you can add the view in two ways.
First, you can create a folder with the
name of controller, which is category
inside the views. And then you can add index
view inside there. Or if you want to do that
directly from the controller, you can just
right click on the action and you have ADD view,
we will be selecting the razor view here. Let's
hit the Add button. Now when you add a razor view,
there are a few configuration that you have to
do. First, what will be the name of the view,
we will give that the same name as the action
method, which is index, then do you want to use
any templates when you create this view? If you
hover here, you can create a view for create
delete details, edit and list. I do not want to
go into those details right now. But we will come
back to that later on. If you change that, then
model and data context class will be enabled.
But we don't want to focus on that right
now. We want to start scratch with an empty
template. Next is a partial view. Partial view
is basically like user controls in the platform.
So it will be rendered inside some other view. So
if you select a partial view, the layout page will
not be used. Because you do not need any master
page if you create a user component, because you
will be calling that inside some other view. We
don't want to take a look at that right now. Let's
keep it simple. Next, we will use the layout page,
we want our view to use the default master page.
So if you keep it blank, it will by default use
the layout that we have set inside the view start,
which is underscored layout, we want it to be
consistent. So that is what we will be using.
And we will hit the Add button. It will scaffold
few dependencies. And then it will create the view
if you had any errors while building the project.
And if you try to scaffold that will fail,
it will ask you to resolve the errors. And only
Once your project is building successfully, you
will be able to scaffold the views. So perfect.
Our view has been created. And let me call this
index category. With that, let's continue. In the
next video. We want to display all the categories
if there are any in the table format, inside
the index view. For that, we will have to
actually retrieve all the category list from our
database inside the index action method. So that
we open up the layout page right here, where we
have two options of index and the privacy page.
Rather than privacy. Let me display the category
right here. And in order to go to the Index page,
how can we navigate to this particular view that
was created, it is inside category controller, and
we have index action method. So here to navigate,
we can define the controller name is category.
And the action method is index. We are not
using areas here. So you can keep that blank.
Or you can also remove them if you want. If you
save this, let's run the project one more time,
and make sure we are able to navigate to our
action method. So we have category when we click
there, perfect, we see the index categories. That
is what we have inside the view. So we are able
to navigate there successfully. Now we need to
retrieve all of the categories from our database.
So let me switch back to database. And just for
Tommy purpose, let me edit the top 200. And let
me add something here. So I have just created
one dummy record inside the table. And right now,
I have created one dummy record inside the table.
Let's go back and we want to retrieve that inside
the category controller. Now I have said before
that we will be using Entity Framework core.
And the main file that we have is the application
DB context. Using that we can access our database
object. Because inside that file, we have
the Categories table. So how can we create
an object of this application DB context?
and use that to call our database and table.
That is the beauty of dependency injection, we
do not have to create an object of this class,
everything will be done for us, because we
have configured that inside our container,
we want to use this service. So because
of dependency injection, we will not have
to create its object, we can think that the
object is already there, we just have to tell
application that please send me the object of
application DB context. How do you request that
inside the controller, you want the application
DB context to work with database. So I will first
create a private read only field,
which will be application DB context.
And we'll call that underscore dB. We will
add the USING statement. And great. Now we
need to tell our application that we need an
implementation of this application DB context
where the connection to database is already made.
And I can recreate some records right away. So for
that, you will have to use constructor see to
our tab tab. And here, whatever is registered
inside the container, you can access that inside
our container, we have registered application DB
context. So inside the constructor, we can
get an implementation of that, just like this.
So this DB will have all the implementation of
connection strings and tables that are needed to
retrieve the data. So we will populate our local
DB object with this implementation. So we'll say
underscore db is equal to dB. And then we can use
this underscore db to retrieve our categories. The
syntax of that is very simple, we will create
a bar let me call this obj category list,
we will first access the underscore dB. And on
there, we will have all the DB set. The DB set
that we want to work on right now is categories.
And we want to convert it to a list and retrieve
that. So it will go to database, it will retrieve
all of the categories, it will convert that
to a list, and it will assign that inside the
category list. You can see how beautiful this is,
you do not have to write a select statement
to retrieve all the categories from the table.
There is no SQL coding required. You just have to
write underscore DB dot the DB set name. And that
will retrieve all the records. You convert that
to a list and you assign that to a variable. Now
how do we test that this is working, we will
add a debugging point by going to this pan,
you see the red dots. If you click here, we are
setting a debugging port. And then if you run
IIS Express here, your application will hit
the debugging point when we load that page.
So if we click on category, it will hit a
debugging point. You can see that is yellow
now. And if you hover on the category
list, you can see there is one count.
If you expand it more, you can see it is the
same record that we created inside the database.
So it goes to the database, it fetches the
categories. And it does that automatically.
We have a list that is already populated here,
we just need to pass this list to our view.
And we can run a for each loop on that
list. And we can display all the categories.
Let's do that in the next video. Let me remove the
breakpoint. And let's do that in the next video.
Know that we have all the categories
inside this particular object,
we can copy that and we will pass that to our
view. And I do not like using variables here.
I am a fan of using the strongly typed
so this will be i enumerable of category
we'll have to press ctrl.to Add the USING
statement. Now since we have an IEnumerable
here and not a list, if you want, you can also
remove the.to list. That is not a required thing.
But if this was a list, then you would have used
the.to list. So we are passing that to our view.
Now that we are passing an
IEnumerable of category to our view,
we need to capture that inside our view as well.
So let me open up that view I have right here.
But if you do not have that open, you can go to
category and index view. So right here, we first
need to capture the model that we Passing from the
controller, for that you will be using activate
sign, and you will write model in all lowercase.
If you make this a capital model that won't work,
in order to fetch what is being passed from
the view, you have to use all lowercase at the
rate model sign. So what exactly is being
passed from the controller action method,
it is an IEnumerable off category, we can copy
this, and we can paste that right here. That way,
our view knows that whatever we receive here
will be an IEnumerable of category. Since it
is I enumerable, we can iterate through that.
Now if you have never worked with razor pages,
you can use both HTML as well as some C sharp
code directly inside the view. So first, let's
use the table attribute. Give that some classes
of Table Table bordered to give it a border.
And we'll say table striped, we can
also give it a style of width 100%.
Inside the table, we have tea head and tea body.
Let me add both of them. So tea head will be for
headers. So we will have a TR tag in there and
a th tag, what will be all the columns that we
have to display. The first one will be category
name, and the next one will be display order.
You can also display the date time and ID if you
want, like we just want to display two columns.
That is the header. Now inside the body,
we will need a for each loop to iterate through
the I enumerable and display the actual values. As
I said before, we can use the shortcode directly
inside the views using the Add the rate directive.
So if you press activate, you will see we have
a for each right here. Syntax is pretty simple,
we will create a wire here we can call that
Obj. And that is inside our model of the page.
So on top we use the lowercase model. But here
model will have the first letter as capital.
So you can see how it is different. That way it
will iterate through all of the properties inside
this model in a for each loop. Now for each of the
property, we want to display a table row. So we
will add TR here in that we want the TD tag. First
we want to display the name. So again, that name
is inside this C sharp variable object. So we will
use the activate sign on we will say obj dot name,
I can give it a width of 50% here. And we can
copy this and paste it one more time. Then we
have display order. So we will say obj dot display
order. Let's give it a width of 30%. This looks
great. Let me save this and run the application.
If we go on category now, you will see our one
category that we have inside the database. This is
looking perfect to display all of the categories.
Next, what I want is Edit and Delete buttons here.
And I want to make this a little bit more pretty.
Before that I will be using boots watch themes.
And let me show you that in the next video
loves a pretty application. Because of that I
want to use boots watch.com, which has free themes
for Bootstrap. If I scroll down, I want
to use the solar theme for our project.
We can hit the download button. And let's
download the bootstrap dot css. Let's open
that file and it is using Bootstrap five. That's
perfect. Let's copy this complete Bootstrap.
And let me stop the application site WW root where
we have CSS or Bootstrap is inside the lib folder.
But here let me just create
a new item style sheet.
We'll call that boot swatch team. And let
me add that I will paste the theme that we
copied and we will be using this in our
project. Looks good. Let me save this.
Another change I would do is inside site dot
css. They have added a btn primary. So let
me remove that and the anchor tag. We will be
using what is there inside our boots watch theme
In order to add this to our project, we
will have to go to underscored layout.
And we should have our CSS at the very top. This
time, we do not want the default bootstrap theme.
We want to use our boots watch theme dot css. Now
since we are using Bootstrap five with boot spot,
if we go to bootstrap.com. Let's click on getting
started in production, we are in Bootstrap five,
let me copy the je s bundle that we have here.
We will copied that and we will go back to our
project inside the underscored layout that
may replace the GS bundle that we have,
with the one that we copied. As of this recording,
the default version of Bootstrap is not five in
dotnet, six, this might change in future. But that
is the reason I'm switching to the latest version
of Bootstrap. With that change, let's run the
application and see if something is different.
Right, you can see a dark theme has been
applied. So things are getting different.
Let me switch back to the boot swatch. And let
me go back to the theme that we have. Let's click
on Preview. Here we have a nav bar, let's use
that. I will copy everything that we have here.
Let's go back to our application. And I will paste
that right here before the nav bar that we have.
Now since we are making changes inside the view,
if you remember, when we created the project,
I enabled the razor runtime compilation. So
what that should do is when we save here,
and if we go back to our application and
refresh, it should load the changes, because
we are making changes directly inside the view.
But that does not seem to work. As you can see.
The reason behind that is we added the package
of razor runtime compilation. Even though these
are razor pages, if you examine the program class
file, we are only adding controllers with views,
we will have to make one small change here on
builder dot services, we will have to add razor
pages. And on that we have ADD razor runtime
compilation. I don't know why it is like that.
I believe in future, they will also add this with
the views. But right now this is only available
with razor pages. So this is one extra
line that we have to add in an MVC project
to get that runtime compilation. With that
change. Let's run the project one more time.
And great, we see the new navigation menu right
here. We don't want everything else here. Let
me comment that, we'll just add the whole and
category. Let me go back here to underscore
layout. And I can just copy the whole. Let
me cut this, I can paste that right here.
Scroll down by we have the other category
controller, cut that and paste that
instead of features. Perfect, I will
remove these two, the one end drop down,
I can just leave that in comments. So that
in future if we want to drop down, we can
use that. And I can remove the nav bar altogether.
Let's go back and refresh. And great. This time,
we did not have to rebuild the application. The
text here is not visible. So let me go back.
And we don't want the text dark
anymore. We can remove that.
And perfect looks much better. If you click on
homepage, it loads the homepage and category
should display all the categories. Great. I
also want to hide this border. So that should be
inside footer. We have border top, we can remove
that. And we can give it a background of BG dark.
Let's go back and refresh. And this looks much
better. So with this now we are using Bootstrap
five in our project and we are using the boots
watch theme. Let's continue in the next video.
Inside our index view, what we can do is we can
add a button here to create a category. So if
we go back to what index, let me add a little bit
of more designing with Bootstrap. But we'll add a
div give it a class Have container and padding
of three. These are just the bootstrap classes
in there, we will add a div, give it a class
of row and padding top of four that may add
attached here, save that and go back. That will
create a new row right here, I want to divide
this row into two parts. By default bootstrap
divides each row into 12 parts if we want. But
if we just want to divide it into parts, then
we will have six in one and six in the other.
So here, we will add a div, give it a class
of column six, that will combine the first six
in one div. And we will add another
div, give it a class of column six.
So that will divide the screen into parts. The
first one we want to display and heading. So
h2, give it a class of text primary. And
we want to display category next year.
Let me save this, go back and refresh. And
looks good. Let me close this container
at the very end. So we'll close that div at the
end. And right here, we want to add a button
right here, we want to add a link inside then
we want to go to a new action method that we
will create inside the category controller
that will be for creating a new category.
So right here, we will say that
should go to the same controller,
which is the category controller. And it should
go to an action method, which will be create.
We do not have that yet. But we will create that
in the next video. We can also add couple of
bootstrap classes btn btn primary. And here we
can say create new category. Let me save this,
go back and refresh. So we have our button.
Let's align this button on the right hand side.
In bootstrap five, we have text and we will save
that and that will bring it to the right side.
Then let me just leave couple of lines here, I can
just add few br tags, then this looks much better.
Now I also want to use some icons here
like font awesome. But with Bootstrap five,
they have given their own sets of icons. So why
don't we use that? If you go to get bootstrap.com,
we have the icons tab. Getting started with all
of these icons is super simple. I used like font
awesome, but you had to register and do lots of
thing. This is available quickly, you just click
the install button and you have the CDN you copy
that go to the underscore layout styles will paste
the CDN. With that the icons are readily available
to us. Let's go back to the Bootstrap. And right
here, let's search for plus, if you scroll down,
we have this plus circle. If you click there, we
have the link here with a copy. And we just paste
it before create category. Let me add a space.
Let's save that. And you will see the icons are
working perfectly. Super easy to get started. With
that we have added icons. But if you click the
Create New category, you will see page not found
that is because it is going inside category
controller Create Action method. But inside
category, there is no action method with the name
of create. So let's add that in the next video.
That may copy the index action method.
And we can paste that one more time,
we will have to change the name here to create
and this will be a get action method. Now when
someone hits the create button, we will give them
the option to enter their name and display order
and create a category. So when the view is
being loaded, you do not have to pass any
model. You can keep that blank and then you
can create a model directly inside the view.
What do I mean by that? Let me create a view
here. We will right click Add View razor view.
We will keep that empty and looks good. Let me
add that. Now previously when we were working with
index, I said that this is the model that will be
passed from the controller. That is true, but it
is not always the case. In our create, we have not
passing anything from our controller. But we still
want to work on the category model. And we want
to fetch its properties when we submit the form.
So for that, also, you will have a model for
this view, that model will be the category model.
So the model that you write inside view is
not always the model that is passed from the
controller. But if you are passing a model from
the controller, it must match what you have inside
the model in the view. But if you are not passing
anything inside the controller, like and create,
then you can find your view with a model based
on the data that you're collecting on the page.
Here we are collecting the name and display
order, we will use category so that we can use tag
helpers to find everything for us. Now, you might
be thinking, what is this new term tag helpers,
I will walk you through that. But before that,
let me create a form here, give it a method
of post, because we will be posting our
data, because we want to create our category.
In that I will create a div, give it a class
of border padding of three and margin top
of four. In there, I will add a div, give it a
class of row and padding bottom of two. And we
will add a heading here, which will have a class
of text primary for the yellow color. And we will
display the heading which is create category. Let
me add an HR here, save this and run the project.
I want to see the view while we are building
that. So if we go to our category now. And if
we hit the Create Category button, it will take
us to the Create category view that we created.
Here, I want to display a label and a text box.
So outside of this tab, I will add another div
give it a class of margin bottom three
in there, we want to display a label,
you can just do label and give it a name like
this. That will work. But what we want to do
is we want to bind everything on this page
with our category model. Because of that,
the dotnet core team has provided tag helpers,
which starts with ASP. So here we have ASP
hyphen, four. When we add that in a label, we
can use any of the properties from our model.
So you can see it is already displaying created
date, time, display, order, name, and ID,
we will select name here, and we do not have to
populate anything else. If we go back and if we
refresh, the output will be seen. Because what it
does here is it displays the name of the property
inside our category model. So we have it as
name. So that is what it will display in the UI
as well. Let's go back to the CREATE VIEW. And now
we want an input field. So we will say input. And
we will just say ASP for Tag Helper, this input is
for name. That way it will do all the binding. And
when this form is posted, it will post an object
of this category class with the name populated,
we can give it a bootstrap class of form control.
Let me save that and refresh. Whoops
I close that. Let me run it again.
And create you can see a text box right here.
This looks good. Let me also add a text box
for the other field which is display order.
So I will just copy this, paste it here as before
will be display order this time. Let me save that,
go back and refresh and create this looks good.
You can notice the name of the label is display
order without a space. And that is because inside
category that is the property name itself. We will
fix that in just a second. But I wanted to show
that now let me add a button here to actually
submit the form and I will add a link to go back
to the Index page of the category controller.
So we'll go to create here and we will
add a button give it a type of submit.
We will also give it some bootstrap classes of btn
btn primary and that will give it a width of 150
pixels. I will call this button as Create.
Next I want to add a link here. This link,
I want to go back to the Index action method
inside the category controller to load all of
the categories. So it is more like a back button
link. So first what is the controller name,
that is the category controller. And what is the
action in there, that is the index action, we will
give it some bootstrap classes btn btn secondary,
and I will also give it a style with the width
of 150 pixels. Within here, we will display
back to list. Let's go back and looks better.
If we click on Back to list you can see that is
functional. Now, in the next video, we want to
hit the create button and create our category.
With that let's continue from the next video.
No, I want to create the category when we populate
the details and hit the Create button. So when we
hit the create button, we will have to create a
post action method inside the category controller.
And in that post action method, we will already
be fetching the category object that is populated
because we used tag helpers. So inside the
category controller, we can copy this create
and paste that one more time. Let me stop the
application. Inside the parameters we will be
receiving a category object, let me call that Obj.
This will be post action method. Now if an action
method is post, we have to write the attribute
HTTP POST. On top of that the dotnet team
has approved and then we also have to validate
anti forgery token anti forgery token is there
to help and prevent the cross site request forgery
attack. What it basically does is inside any forms
that you have inside the application, it will
automatically inject a key there. And that key
will be validated at the step. That key must
be valid to prevent cross site request forgery.
I have explained the cross site request forgery
and the Validate anti forgery token in much
details inside free content on dotnet mastery.
If you search and look for cross site request
forgery, you can find that video on YouTube and
watch that I do not want to change the focus of
this course. So they will just validate
that token on all of the post request.
This is not required. But I will highly recommend
that to avoid the cross site request forgery.
Now once we have the category object that is
populated with name and the display order,
we want to create that record inside the database.
So to do that, we will use our DB context.
And on there we have the categories.
Then in order to retrieve categories,
we did not have to write anything else. But
when we have to add something to the table,
we have the add method there. And you can
see it expects a category entity. We already
have that inside the OBJ. That is what the user
populated. So we will add that to our database.
Now once you add it to the database, it is not
pushed to the database right now. It will be
pushed to the database. When you run the command
underscore DB dot Save Changes. At that point it
goes to the database and saves all the changes.
Once the changes are saved, we have returned view
here. That will take us back to the same category
view. Let's see when we are done. Let's go back
to the index so that we can see the new category
that was created. So rather than return view, we
want to redirect to an action, we want to redirect
to the index action, it will look for this index
inside the same controller. If you had to go
to an action method in some other controller,
you can define the controller name right
here. But since we are in the same controller,
we can just mention index and that will work.
Let's run our application and try this out.
Let's go to our category. And let's create a new
category. I will call this Test display order 12.
And create you can see it has been created. If
we go back to our SQL Server, let me close this.
And if we do select top 1000 Now we see
two records. So perfect. This is working as
expected. We are able to create a new category
now. But our create category is not perfect.
If you hit the create button, you will run
into an exception. Let me switch back to the
project. And you can see the exception is
cannot insert. Now, inside the column name,
we did not have any validations. But inside
database, we said that this was a not nullable
column. So when the Entity framework code tries to
save, it gives the exception, pretty smart. But we
have to be much smarter to handle the validations.
Let's take a look at them in the next video.
Now when we try to create a category without
any fields populated, right now we see some
error message because it cannot add an object
when in the database, we have validation.
But that is not a good approach. Because we are
throwing exception. In that case, what should
happen is we should handle our validations
inside the server side, which is controller
as well as inside client side, which is inside
the CREATE VIEW. So how do we handle validations?
Let's first do that at the server side. So when
we receive a model here, we can check whether this
model is valid or not. And what defines a valid
model is the validations that we have right here.
name should be a required property. So let's go
back. And let's make sure that our model is valid.
In order to check that with dotnet core, we have
model state.is valid, that will determine if the
model is valid or not. If that is valid, we want
to create and redirect to index. If that is not
valid, we just return back to the view with the
object. Let me run this and show you what happens.
I'll add a debugging point on if the model
state is valid. So let's run our application.
Let's try to create a category with no fields
populated. We hit our breakpoint. And if you
examine the is valid flag is false. So
our model state is not valid. Great.
But now which property in our model state is not
valid? It is important to know that because right
now we just have two properties, it could be
possible we have over 50 properties in a model.
So in that case, you hover on model state, you
expand that inside the error counts, you see we
have two errors. If you hover on the values here,
Result view, you will see which properties are not
valid. You can see display order is not valid, as
well as name is not valid. Let's continue here.
And this time let me populate display order
and hit the create button one more time,
model state will still be not valid. But
this time if you examine the error count
is only one because we already fixed one of
the errors by providing display order. So now
you can see display order is valid, but name is
still invalid because it is a required field.
That's it server side validations are working.
But with that it would be helpful if we are
displaying an error message right here,
so that user can know why it is failing.
Doing that is super simple. We will remove the
breakpoint here. And let me go to the View.
Just like we have ASP for Tag Helper, we
also have a Tag Helper for validation.
So inside name, we can add a span tag. And we
have the Tag Helper ASP validation for on this
you have to define the model. So we want to check
validations for name here. And if there are any
errors, we want to display them in red color. So
we can give it a bootstrap class of text danger,
we will copy this span and we will paste that
for display order as well. With that in place,
make sure to save this and we will go back and
refresh the page. Let me just reload this. And
this time if you try to hit the create button, you
can see the default error message is displayed.
The first one that we have is name is a required
field and display order value now is invalid
because it's an integer. So with that we can
display the default error messages right here.
So with that we have our server side validations
in which it checks at the controller level if the
model state is valid or not. If it is not valid,
it populates the model state with error message.
It returns back the obj and it automatically
displays the validations that we have added,
we did not have to write JavaScript or any
other complex code. It is doing all of that,
with the help of tag helpers. Let's continue in
the next video. With server side validations.
What if you want to display a summary at the top
with all the error message, if you want to do that
dotnet core has a solution for that. You will need
a div this time and not a span that you were using
with validation for. And inside tip, you can
see we have a Tag Helper ASP Validation Summary,
this will be all in this case, it will display all
the validations at the top in a summary format.
Once we make this change, let's go back and
refresh here. If you hit Create rate, now you see
the error messages at top as well. When you select
all it will display models as well as properties.
If you want to limit that you can change
that to model only and none. But if you are
using Validation Summary, I personally like
all, and this is great. Now along with that,
what if we want to add some custom validation?
Like let's say inside the controller here, we want
to make sure that we do not add any category
which has the same name and display order.
How can we add that to the validation. So
before we confirm if the model state is valid,
we can check here if obj dot name is equal equal
to OBJ dot display order, we will have to convert
that to a string. If this is the same, we want
to tell our model state that this is not valid.
So for that on the model state itself, we
can add custom model errors. Here we have
a key and value pair, you can give any key name
that you want, we will call this custom error.
If you want you can also use string dot empty.
But since this is a key, you have to make sure
that you do not use the same key two times.
Let me add a custom error that the display
order cannot exactly match the name. Now since
we are making the change inside the controller,
we will actually have to restart our application
to see this change. If we were working with the
view, we did not have to restart. Let's go to our
category and try to create a category with the
same name and display order. This time, you can
see we have our custom validation that is being
displayed in the summary. Now if we did not have
summary, then this would not have been displayed.
But what if you want to display the
error message inside name as well,
it is pretty simple, we will stop the application
and the key, we will just change that to name.
Because inside the category object, if you
notice, we have name. So inside controller,
we are adding a new error inside the name
property. Let's run this and give that a try.
Let's go to our category and try to create a new
category with the same name and display order.
Great. Now you see it displays input cases.
So with this, we have seen how to add custom
error message. But all of the validations that
we have so far are done on the server side.
Every time you hit the create button,
you will see the page will reload.
So that means we are hitting server every time.
Even if the name and display order are empty.
We go back and hit the server
because the page reloads.
What if we want to make all of this validations
on client side? Let's do that in the next video.
Now if you want to do the basic model
validations like name and value for the
display order on the client side, it is pretty
simple. If you examine inside the shared folder,
we have a validation scripts partial that is using
jQuery dot validate. It is inside a partial view.
So if we want to do client side validations
we just have to include this partial view
in our view. So that brings the big question. How
do we use a partial view, we have not created one,
but we are using the one that is already
available. It's not a rule, but typically it's
good to name partial views with underscore. So
even if in future when we create a partial view,
we will follow that convention. Now in order
to include a partial view it is pretty simple.
You can directly say partial and then you have to
write name of the view. So make sure to type the
exact name if you have a special mistake there,
then this won't be included. With that the errors
go away. But inside the partial view, if you open
up, we have script files. So we need to add that
inside a script section of our view. So here
we will have to create a section for scripts.
And in there, we will have to add our partial
view, and that to inside razor syntax.
Once you add this, let's run the application
one more time and see the magic. Let's go to
our category. And let's try to create a new
category, we will hit the create button,
you see, we get the validations. But we are not
going to server this time. All the validations
are done on client side, because of the script
that we included. To double check, you can just
add a debugging point here and hit the Create
button. It will never reach our debugging point,
it will reach our debugging point if
the name and display order are the same,
then the client side validations are valid. The
validation that fails is the server side custom
validation that we added. And if you continue,
perfect, you can see that in action. So with this,
we can see how easy it was to add client side
validation. Let's continue in the next video
that we have added the client side validations I
want to show you one more thing. Right now we have
the default message that is being displayed.
Right now we have the default message that is
being displayed. On top of that you can see right
now in display order, there is no space that is
available. And it is the same with the validation.
The reason behind this is if we go to our category
model, you can see that's the property name. And
that is exactly what is being displayed. So if we
want to display something that is not the same
as property name, we have display name here,
which is inside component model. And here we can
just give whatever name we want to display. So
let's add a space there. And it will correct that
automatically. Let's run this and give that a try.
Let's go to our category, create category. And
this time you see in errors, we have a space
labels, we have a space, and perfect. Looks good.
Now if you go on the official documentation,
there are quite a few data annotations that you
can use. We see the required one that we saw,
we also have a range attribute. I won't go into
all of them, you can explore them when you want,
you can see the display attribute that
we used. Now let's just try one more,
which is the range attribute that specifies a
range for a field. So let me just close this,
and we'll stop the application. Inside our
display order, we will add a range attribute.
And here we have minimum and maximum value.
So let's say minimum is one maximum is 100.
So now if the display order is not in the
range, it will give an error message. But
the error messages that we see on the screen with
validations are also customizable. So with range,
if we want some other error message, we have
that property right here. And we can give
a custom error message that will have our custom
error message as display order must be between
one and 100 only with two exclamation. Let's
run our application and see that in action.
Let's hit Create we have our required one, let
me add something more than 100 and you can see it
directly displays our custom validation. With that
you can see everything is working as expected.
And we saw how to add custom error messages,
range validation and how to use display name.
Now inside our CREATE VIEW, I will
hide or comment the Validation Summary
because we don't want that right now.
The inline validations are sufficient.
Let me go back and remove the debugging point.
Everything looks good so far. From the next video
we want to work on editing and deleting
our category. Now that we have the Create
functionality working as expected,
let's work on the added functionality.
For added we will go to category controller and
just like we have the Create get and create post.
We will copy that And paste it one more time.
This time, we'll we'll call them for any.
So let me change the action method names here.
One thing that will be different for edit is when
the page is loaded, it will display the existing
functionality of the category that was selected.
Here, we will retrieve an integer, which will
be ID. Based on that ID, we have to retrieve
the category details and display them. So we can
check here if Id is now or if ID is equal to zero.
In those cases, we will return back not found,
because that is an invalid ID. If that is not the
case, we will retrieve the category from database
or category from dB. And we will extract that
using our underscore DB dot categories. Now this
will retrieve complete list of all the tables.
So on that we have few more ways of finding one
of the entity. First is single or default, which
returns only one element every time, it will throw
an exception if there is more than one element,
id is a primary key, so there is no chance that
there will be more than one element. Similarly,
we have single, the difference between single
and single or default is single will throw an
exception if no elements are found for that ID,
but single or default will just return empty if
there are no elements. So default will not throw
an exception if the element is not found. Similar
to single or default, we also have first and
first our default, the difference between single
or default. And first, our default is that single
or default will throw an exception if there are
more than one elements. First 34 will not throw
an exception, it will return the first element
of the list. So if more than one elements are
found, first, our default will return one element
singular default will throw an exception. Last but
not the least, we have one method which is Find.
Find basically tries to find that based on the
primary key of the table, we know that ID is the
primary key. So we can use Find here and pass
the ID. It we'll find the category based on
that ID and assign that to our variable. Let me
also show you how we can use first our default,
with find you just had to pass the ID with first
our default, you have to pass an expression here
where we will have a generic object, let's
call that u. And we will say u goes to u.id
should be equal to the ID that we have, if
that matches in any of the categories will
retrieve that and give me the first one out of
them. Let me copy this and paste it one more time.
For single or default, the syntax will be same,
we will just use single our default. And let me
call this variable single. So these are three
ways to retrieve a category from database based
on the ID. I will comment two of them out, but I
wanted to show you how that could be done using
Entity Framework core. Now once we retrieve the
object, we will check here if category from dB.
If that is now that means again, we will
return not found. If we find that category,
we will return that category to the view. So
next what we will do is we will create this view
which will have the category loaded. And we just
need to display that that view will look exactly
same as the CREATE VIEW. But the only thing
different will be that it will be for edit page.
So we can copy the view that we have for
create insert category folder and paste
that one more time. I can rename this to edit to
give us a head start. Let's open that edit view
our model will be the category model, but rather
than create category, this will be added category.
Now when we added a category, we want the
validations. So that will stay the same. The
button text we will change that from create
to update. And it is just submitting back.
We do not have which action method it should
submit to. If you do not provide any name here,
it will by default submit to the same action
that is of the name of the cat. So since the
get is from edit, it will post back to
the same action method which is added.
But if you want to be explicit about the action,
you can use that with the Tag Helper ASP action.
And you can write edit like that. So if you want
you can be explicit, but that is not required,
the backdoor list will stay the same. So with
that in place, if we want to see this in action,
let's go to the index view of category where we
are displaying everything, I want to add a link to
navigate to the Edit action method. That will be
three columns here, let me add another th tag. And
inside the TD, we will have one with the links.
So inside this TD, we can add a div with a class
of ID, 75 and btn group, we can also give that a
roll of group in there, let me add an anchor tag.
And we will use tag helpers inside this anchor
tag. This will be for edit. And if we go back,
and if we open up the bootstrap icon, let's try to
find an icon for edit, we have this pencil square,
let me copy that and paste that here. Let's run
the application. And we will get back to the Index
in just a second. While the application loads,
let's get back here. So this added should take
us to category controller and edit action method.
So if we go back here, we want the ASB controller,
it has to go to the category controller,
ASB action, it should go to the Edit action.
That is great. But if we go take a look at our
controller action method, it also expects an ID.
So we have to pass that ID with our link. We can
pass custom wave tables here. So we can say ESP
route. And then what is the name of the variable
that is ID right here. So we will just say ID
here, this will have to bind with our object.
So we'll say add, we have obj.id. You can see
how dynamic we can get with the razor pages. With
that. Let's go back and refresh. Go to category,
we should see the edit button. Yep, that is
here. You can see if you hover on edit, you
can see the URL where the ID is changing. If you
click edit here, it will take us to edit category,
and it automatically populates the name and
display order. Our back to list is also working
as expected. To make this button look pretty,
we can just add two CSS classes btn btn, primary
and some margin. Let's go back and refresh. And
this looks much better. So I added cat action
method is working as expected. In the next
video, let's work on updating our category.
Now we are able to load the category that we want
to edit. When the user hits the Update button,
it will go to category controller, we
have the post action method for edit,
you can have the same validation that we had
there. But if all the validations are valid,
we do not want to call the add, we want to
call the update method on our categories DB
set. This is a built in method with EF core where
based on the primary key, it will automatically
update all of the properties. And you do not
have to do any manual update, it will take a
look at the obj right here and it will find its
primary key retrieve that from the database,
it will check all the other properties where
the values have changed, and it will update all
of those. So you can see it is handling all the
complexity. And we just need an update statement
to update any of the category based on the ID.
After that, make sure that you are saving the
changes and we are redirecting back to the Index
action. If you examine here, you can see all the
options that are available with RTP sent we have
add remove add a thing at range that will add
multiple objects at the same time. We have update,
and much more. For this time, we'll select update,
and we will have to restart the application
since we made some changes to the controller.
Let's go to our category. And let's
try to edit any of the category.
And great you can see update is working
successfully. Now the last part that I want you
guys to implement yourself is to add a button or a
link here to delete any of the category. Once you
do that, it should take you to a details page like
edit category But this will say delete category
and the fields will be disabled, then that will
be a button to delete. And when you click that
on the post, it will delete the category and take
you back to the Index page. It is exactly same as
what we did with edit category. But rather than
update, you will have to find what keyword to use
to delete the category. Also, I want to show you
that inside edit our validations are working. If
you hit update here, you can see it does not
let you update your callback, the data stays
the same. So all the validations are working
as expected. But in the Delete category,
we will not need any validations because you
have to make sure that the fields are disabled.
So good luck with the assignment. And I'll
show you how to do that in the next video.
Last functionality we want to work on is the
Delete functionality inside category. So we
will copy edit as as, and we will paste
that one more time both GET and POST,
I will change this to delete. And we will use the
same name right here for the post action method.
When we are deleting a category, we want to
retrieve that category. And we want to display
that on the view. So this functionality stays
the same with the get action method. Now with
the post action method, you can either push the
complete object, or you can just pass the ID here.
So we will have integer ID. And based on that ID
we will first retrieve that category. Now I do not
need any model state validations. So I will remove
them, all I have to do is based on the ID, I have
to retrieve the category. So I'll say variable obj
is equal to underscore DB dot category start find
based on the ID we will find that if there is
no we will return not found. Else on categories
we have removed. And we will remove the object,
save the changes, redirect back to the Index page.
That looks perfect. But we see an error with the
name, we cannot have same signature with the name
and the parameters for to action method. So
far. Now let me rename this to delete post.
Let's work on adding the Delete view it
will be same as added because we will be
displaying them. So let me copy edit, paste it
one more time, I will rename this as delete.
Let me close all the other views so that we don't
confuse ourselves. This will be delete category
and the button let me make it danger. Since we
are deleting, we do not want any validations and
the fields will be disabled. So let me copy that
as well. Now the post action limb is added. But
we have renamed the POST method to delete post.
So we will copy that and paste that right here.
Let's run our application and give this a try. Let
me go back and add a debugging point right here.
Let's go to our category. And we
forgot to add the delete button
inside the index view. I will copy this and
paste it one more time. This will be for delete,
rather than square we will have to look for
delete icon. So let me look for a trashcan.
The get action will be delete. So we will use
that. Let's go back and refresh. We have edit and
delete. That may give it a different color. And
perfect. Now if you try to hit the delete button,
it will take you to the Delete category. Let's
see what happens when we hit Delete button.
It will hit our breakpoint and you examine
the ID is now. Now why is this ID No,
it was not now when we were editing button
delete this is no. The reason behind that is
inside Delete. Let me hit continue here. And it
will take us to not found page that's perfect.
But the reason behind that is inside Delete. All
of the fields for our model is disabled. If one
of them was enabled, it is primary key. That's
why it was automatically being set on the forum.
So in this case, what we will do is we will have
an input field with the Tag Helper ASP for ID.
That's the only field we care about. And we will
keep it hidden since it is inside the form when
the form is posted. We will retrieve that ID
right here. Let's go back. And let me refresh.
Let's hit the delete button. This time the
ID is populated. So now if you hit continue,
now, if you are editing, you make some change, you
get this error message. But I believe with Visual
Studio 2022, they are just giving that right
now. And it will be fixed later on. In that case,
just rerun the application. So let's go to
category here and try delete one more time.
Perfect that category was deleted. But that delete
is working as expected. But I want to show you
one last thing. Right now inside delete, we have
the action as delete post. What if we want it to
be Delete? In this case, it won't work because
the controller will know that the action method
name here is delete post for post. So if you
want to explicitly give that a different name,
we have action name attribute right here. And we
can give it delete. That way the controller will
know that if a request comes in for delete action
method HTTP POST inside the category controller,
that is this particular action method. So let
me run that and show you that this also works.
So let's go to category and
delete one more category. Perfect.
So with that all the functionality
are working as expected.
What to display some alerts when someone deletes
edits, or create a category on the category
index view? How will we do that? For that we
have something called as temp data in dotnet core
temp data has been provided with one single
purpose, whatever we want to store in temp
data stays there for only one request.
After that, if you refresh the same page,
that will be gone. So that is perfect for
displaying alerts of successful or failure
qualification. Let's take a look at how we'll
be doing that. Let's say right now that when we
create or edit or delete anything, we will
add something to attempt data of success.
So once the Create is successful here, before
we return back, we want to use temp data,
it is directly available as you can see, so
temp data and then you have to give any key
inside there. So let me call this temp data
of success. And we will store a message there
that category created successfully. On create
post. If they are editing admin store category
updated successfully. In delete, I will say
category deleted successfully. So we are
storing some string inside temp data with the key
of success. Now where do we want to extract this,
we want to extract that inside the index view.
So at the top here, we can check if temp data of
success is not no. The main important thing is the
key name must exact match. If you use a different
key name, this will not work. So if this does
match inside an h2 tag, let me display temp data.
And the value inside that. Let's save this
and run our application to see what happens.
With that change, let me try
to create a new category.
Great, you can see we have category created
successfully. Now since this is in temp data,
if you refresh, this will go away. So it only
stays in memory for just one redirect. And
after that it goes away. If we try to edit any
of the category, we get the error of course,
we see category updated successfully. When
we delete, we get the deleted successfully
if you refresh that goes away. So this is great
when you have to display notifications on some of
the actions that are performed. Now this temp
data can be used throughout the application
and not just one page. So why not when we are
checking this temp data success and displaying
that do that at a global level. So we do
not have to add this in all the pages for
that partial views will be a perfect candidate.
We can have some code inside the partial view
and we can call that partial view everywhere we
fought because right now it is four lines of code,
but it is possible that this code will increase
drastically. When you do something fancy
for notification. So let's move this code inside
a partial view and see how we can count that.
Now that we have added a code to display
some of the alerts and notification,
we want to make sure that this code is applicable
on almost all the pages. Because if in future,
we add more pages, we don't want to copy
and paste the same code in other places.
So the best thing is inside the shared
folder, we will create the partial views.
That is the folder that I like to place all of
my partial views, we will start the application,
right click Add View, we will go with the
razor view, not the empty one. And here,
we will select Create as a partial view, we did
not do that earlier. But now we will do that.
That will create an empty partial view. I forgot
to give that a name. So I'll have to rename this,
once it is created. It's just a view, we
will change that to underscore notification.
What we want to do is the temp data check
that we have here. Let me copy and paste that
here. And it will do its check. Since we have a
temporary data for success, we can also implement
a temporary data for error. So we can display
both success and error notifications. So great.
Now inside index, we can just say partial here.
And we can say name is equal to underscore
notification. Pretty clean, right? Let's say in
future, you want to add this to multiple pages,
you just have to add this partial
tag. And that will be done.
Let's run our application and see if
our partial view is working as expected.
That's quiet to create a new category.
And grid that is working. If we refresh
that goes away. So with that our partial views
are working as expected. Then displaying the
text as an alert. Why don't we use something
fancy like toaster. So we have toaster js.
So with toaster difficult that GitHub page, we
have a JavaScript notification that we can use.
If you go to demo here and hit show toast, this
notifications are much cleaner and easier to read.
In order to use that, we will copy the minify
js and css files. Let's add that to our project.
In the underscore layout of the CSS
file, we will be adding right here.
So we'll say link, Arielle is equal to stylesheet.
And the href, let's go back and copy just the CSS.
So we will copy this and paste it right
here. Now the GS file will be required
at the underscored notification level. So
we will have to go back, copy the GS file.
And we need to include that right here.
So we will have to use a script here, SRC.
Let's paste that. Also, when we are using a
toaster, we will need the jQuery reference
that is inside an IB we have the jQuery di st
jQuery dot main dot j s. So we will have to add
both of them in both the places. Next we
need the toaster alert. So if we go back,
we should have a usage right here. We have toaster
dot warning toaster dot success, we will use it
exactly like this. So if we go back here, if
we have success that is populated, we need a
JavaScript code. So we'll add a script tag. We
will say type is equal to text forward slash
JavaScript. And I've used toaster dot success and
display everything inside temp data of success.
Make sure here you are using the single quotes.
And then you need to activate sign for accessing
the C sharp variable. Let's copy this clip tag
and paste that for error. And this looks great.
So with that we have added toaster Jas in our
website. If we go back even while the application
is running, these are just the JavaScript
changes. So you can refresh the page here
and let's try to edit some thing in the category.
And great, we see our toaster alerts here,
and everything is working as expected. Now that
say this notification is something you will have
across all the pages. In that case, it does not
make sense to add this one line in all the pages,
even though it's just one line, it just doesn't
make sense. So rather than adding this in all the
pages, you can add that in underscored layout.
And that will be included in all the pages.
So just before render body where we have all the
body that we render for the page, we will paste
our partial view. And that will make sure that it
is included in all the pages of your application.
So make sure that you include only things
that are needed across all the pages,
because this will be loaded every time your
page loads. So with that, if we go back and
refresh and try to delete a category, our
toaster alerts are working as expected.
Now that our application is up and running, and
everything looks scared, I want to show you one
thing with the controller, we added the controller
ourselves and we also created all the views.
But with dotnet core, we have some help if you
want. So if we try to add a controller, this time,
we will implement the same logic work with MVC
controller with views using Entity Framework.
We will hit add here. And this will create an MVC
controller with views using Entity Framework on a
model. So we will select our model category. On
that we want the CRUD operations. Let's select
a data context that will be used to access the
database. And we will give our controller a name.
I will leave the default name. But rather than
categories, I will say categories term controller,
since I want to delete that later on. Let's
add this and see what happens. This will
scaffold everything for us, it will create a
new category stem controller, and it will create
the views for create, edit, delete details
and index. You can see the new controller,
it has all the action methods as well as the post
action methods. And inside the categories temp,
it has added five views. Let's run
the application and see the change.
In order to navigate there, we will
have to manually type category stem
it takes us to the view here
where we have the index view,
it displays our category, we
can create a new category here.
With this, it also asks us to
input the created date time,
let's do that you can see it is not as efficient
because it does not know that created date
time will be the default one. So it asks the
user to input that. But you can create that,
edit that back, view the details. And
you can also delete any of the request.
So all the crud functionalities with the views are
ready for you and generated in just a minute. But
you'll have to spend time on customizing this
based on your requirement. The reason I did not
want to go into this directly is I wanted you to
spend some time and learn how to do everything
from scratch. But once you know this, you can
take a look at the controller action method,
most of the code will be the same. But that is
also an option that is available. With that,
that may remove the temp controller that we added
as well as the views. With that our application
is complete. Let's see how we can deploy this to
Azure and see everything live on the internet.
And the final task is to deploy an application
to Azure. So for that, you will have to create
an account on portal.azure.com. I already have an
account. If you are signing up for the first time,
you will get $200 of Free credit that you can
use. The first thing that we have to do in here
is we need to create a SQL Server and a database
inside that. So we can create our search for SQL
databases. And let's hit the Add button. Usually
I like creating everything from Visual Studio
but SQL Server I'd like to create here. That
way, I can easily see all the configuration,
you will select the subscription that you have.
And in there, we can create a resource group.
I will call this resource group as taught at
mesh tree underscore course. And then let's
enter a database name, we will contact dotnet
mastery underscore dB, we do not have a server.
So let's create a server, the server name will
be unique. So I will use start at mastery server.
And then we need an admin login. We cannot use
admin here, that won't work. So I will just use
admin SQL for password, you can use something
secure, select your location, and hit OK.
Now next option is to be one to use elastic
pool, we will say no there and in the server
location that's not available. So let me select
some other location HDLs too. And let's hit OK.
Then you need to select the compute flash
storage, we will select Configure database there,
and I will use the lowest option which is
basic here. And that is five usd per month.
Let's apply. I do not want to pay more for the
subscription. So I'm going with the lowest option,
the redundancy backup, that is perfectly fine
with me. Let me hit review, let's create. We're
going to hit Create here. And it will take a while
to configure our database and set everything up.
And perfect our database has been created. If
we click go to resource, it will take us to
SQL database. Now one thing that you will have
to do is if you want to access this database,
from your local SQL Server, you will have to
select the Set firewall settings and add your
client IP that will enable your client IP and
you can access the database from SQL Server.
Let's hit the Save button to add your client IP
there. Once that is done, let's go back to SQL
Server. And we need to connect to that server.
So we will hit OK here. Go back to the resource.
And we have connection string.
Let me copy the server name here.
Go back and paste it. And we will use SQL
server authentication. We have admin SQL
and password. Let's press Connect. Great,
we are able to connect to our SQL Server.
So with that in place, let's continue from the
next video. That will close the other tabs here.
Now we are able to connect to our database from
SQL Server. Let's go back to our project. And we
want to deploy our website to ensure for
that, we will right click on the project
and hit publish. We will do all the setup directly
from Visual Studio to create an app service.
And we will use the database that we created.
Here we will select Azure, hit the next button,
we will be using Azure App Service for Windows.
If you are not signed in, make sure to sign in
with the same account that you have used
to create the database on Azure portal.
You will select the subscription name here, and
we don't have any app service that are running.
So we will create a new app service here.
And we need to give a meaningful name.
I will call this bulky book web. And
because of that the final site name
will be bulky book web dot Azure Websites dotnet.
We will have our subscription resource group. If
you do not have one, you can just create one. It
is just any name that you want. That is more like
a folder structure in which you can organize
everything together. Next is the hosting plan.
By default, there is as one hosting plan, I want
to use the free hosting plan. So we will select
new here. And we will select the free plan
that is available with Azure. Let me hit
OK here and hit the Create button. This will take
a few minutes, but it will create and configure
your app service. Once the app service is created,
we will have to configure the connection string
and then in the new database that is created. We
need to make sure that migrations are executed.
Perfect the system. Let's hit finish here.
And inside dependencies you see we have SQL
Server database. You can either configured this
here. Or if you just click the Edit button here,
it will display the database, which has a
connection string, if you go back to your portal,
and we will have to go to our SQL database,
we have the connection string right here,
we will copy this, and we will paste that
here, we just need to make sure a few things,
we just need to make sure that password
is populated. Let me do that here.
User ID looks good. We will say that we want to
use this connection string at runtime. Let me copy
this. And inside the Entity Framework migrations,
we want to apply migrations on Publish,
we will paste the connection string here as well.
Let me go here to make sure password and user ID
looks good. And the last option is since we are
using dotnet, six, it is not available inside the
API service. So for that, we will have to change
the mode to self contained that we'll have a self
contained environment with dotnet six. With that,
let me save this. And let's publish. When it will
try to run the migration in the logs, we will
see one error with the IP address. Let's wait
for that. And you can see here it is failing
here. So it should give us the error message
pretty soon. And perfect. We see that here. It
should be with the IP address. And there you go,
you can see it cannot access this IP address that
is the server IP. So let me copy that. And I will
paste that there notepad, let me copy this IP
address, we will go back and inside our database
we will set the server
firewall at that IP address.
And we will save that perfect. Now that should
not be an issue. Let's hit publish one more time.
This time, it should be able to push all
the migrations and deploy our code to Azure.
Once everything is done, it will load the website
which is bulky book.as, your website's dotnet.
Great, it automatically opened up and perfect.
This looks great. If we go to category,
there won't be any category. But
we can create a new category here.
And our alerts are also working. So perfect. With
this, we have seen how we can deploy our website
to Azure. That being said, this is only for
testing, but the SQL database that we have, we are
getting charged for that. So let me remove all the
resources. And we will also delete this profile.
The reason I want to delete is I only wanted to
show you how easy it is to deploy your code to
Azure. So with that, let's go to our resources,
select all of them and let's delete them. So,
with that we have seen the CRUD operations that
we can do with category using MVC in dotnet six.
So first of all, congratulations on completing the
CRUD operations using dotnet six MVC. We have seen
quite a few things in this course. But right now,
we are just getting started with dotnet core.
And there is a lot more to explore and learn
when it comes to dotnet core. Even though this
course has come to an end, I have advanced courses
that will take you from the basics that you have
learned here all the way to exploring new concept.
Let me walk you through some of those concepts.
In the full course of dotnet core MVC, we will
take what we have built so far and convert that
to an anterior architecture, because that is a
real world scenario. Because that is a scenario
that is adopted with most complex project, then we
do not interact directly with the data context in
our main project, we will be using a repository
pattern and unit of work to interact with our
database. So we will see dependency injection and
how to inject that using a repository pattern.
Then we will further split our
project inside areas in dotnet core,
which is a folder like structure, but everything
gets much more organized. We have seen temp data,
but we will see ViewBag and view data with data
attend core and see how all of them are different.
Next we will use with a loads rich text editor
data tables with dotnet core and API calls
with any application authentication and
authorization leaves very important role.
And dotnet team has given us the razor Class
Library, which is identity in the dotnet world.
That makes all of the authentication super simple,
because the basic functionality and table
structure is already implemented for us.
So we will see how to scaffold that identity
in MVC application. Next, with authorization,
we will see how roles play an important role.
And how can we modify our application based on
the role of the user that is logged in. In a real
world scenario, we also accept payments. So I will
show you how to accept payments using Stripe and
also give refunds when the order is cancelled.
Session is one of the key feature that was very
helpful, but traditional MVC application. With
dotnet core also session is not gone. We just need
to do a little configuration and add session to
our project. And we will see that in action. Most
of the applications will send emails in some way.
I will show you two approaches, one using the SMTP
server and second using applications and grid.
Then with the modern applications,
we have social logins like Facebook,
Twitter, and so on. So I will show you
how the dotnet team has made it easy
to integrate social logins
with the help of Facebook.
Lastly, there are some advanced concepts like view
component how to see database with DB initializer.
And once the data is seated in the database, our
final goal is deploying the application to Azure.
So you can see there are quite a few topics
that we will cover in the advanced cores.
But with that you will get a solid foundation to
build your real world project. And if you'd like
this free course, please subscribe and like this
video, and I will have more free content uploaded
every month. So good luck with your
journey of dotnet core and happy coding